- Guys, if you haven't heard,
Trash Taste is going on tour!
Yes, me and the boys are
gonna be touring North America
in the month of September and October.
So if you live anywhere
near St. Paul, Chicago,
Cleveland, Detroit, Toronto,
Boston, Philadelphia,
New York City, Washington, DC,
Raleigh, Nashville,
Orlando, Dallas, Austin,
Kansas City, Denver,
Salt Lake City, Phoenix,
LA, San Francisco, Seattle, or Portland,
we are coming to you!
All the dates should
be on screen right now.
Tickets have been on sale,
I believe LA is already sold out
and other cities are already
very close to selling out.
So if you wanna get your tickets today,
go to trashtastetour.com,
that is trashtastetour.com.
Links in the description as always.
(sighing)
- We are so sorry, guys.
- So sorry.
- We really, really messed up big time.
- A lot of times, which you
can now watch on our Patreon.
(Joey laughing)
- We do, we do mess up a lot.
- Yeah, we do, we do.
- For those of you who are our $5 patrons,
by the way, thank you very much,
you guys will know that you'll
get early access to clips
as well as uncensored and uncut episodes.
But we have extra stuff for you guys now,
monthly behind the scenes content.
- We fuck up so much that we
can make a whole new video
of just our fuck-ups every single month,
and we will present that to you,
to our patrons on the $5 tier.
So if you do wanna go and
watch those, you can do,
but, just for, you know,
'cause we're feeling a little generous,
the first behind the
scenes will be available,
you can just smash that link down below
to the YouTube unlisted link
and you can watch the Trash
Taste behind the scenes.
- So head over to patreon.com/trashtaste
if you wanna see what we have to offer.
On with the episode.
- We always talk way (beep) louder.
Let me tell you about this thing!
- You beat your guests down, they're like-
- It's like, shut up, don't talk!
- I'll wait my turn.
Permission to speak?
(mellow music)
- Hello, and welcome
to another very special
episode of Trash Taste.
We are joined by another guest today.
I'm sorry, I completely forgot,
it's been a while since I've hosted.
I'm your host for today, Garnt,
and with me are as usual, the boys.
- What up?
- And today we have a very special guest.
Now, in case there is
one person in YouTube
who doesn't know who you are,
do you want to introduce
yourself and what you do?
- Oh my God, that's a lot of pressure.
My name is Anthony Padilla.
Some people say Padilla,
I'm totally fine with that,
but I do like to say
Padilla like tortilla.
(Garnt laughing)
That's how I get people to memorize it.
Let's see, so,
God, how deep do we want to
go into this history here?
- You're a YouTube legend!
(Anthony and Garnt laughing)
Just admit it, Anthony!
- We have two-plus hours.
- We have two-plus hours-
- Are we doing two-plus hours?
- Yeah, let's do it.
- Okay, let's get deep, guys.
So I started with my friend Ian.
I started a YouTube channel
called Smosh in 2005,
- Never heard of it.
- What's Smosh?
- 17 years, half of my age ago.
- Oh my God.
- Jesus.
- Half of my age ago.
- Oh my God.
- Half your life has been on YouTube.
- Half of my life, yes.
Oh shit, I'm having to
rethink so many things.
I'm gonna need that 2 1/2 hours.
And then in 2017, I kind of
split off to do my own thing.
Been doing an independent channel
which has slowly evolved
into me kind of doing deep dive interviews
with either groups of people or one person
that has some kind of
popularity surrounding them.
And we drill in deep into the
psychology behind blowing up
or if it's a group of people,
I like to kind of get in
there and understand them.
I feel like so many people
have preconceived ideas
about what a group or what
a label or identity means,
so I like to kind of show
that there is variation
and nuance from individual to individual.
- Yeah, they're really good.
- Thank you.
- I mean, this is pretty intimidating,
'cause not only are you
like, the OG of YouTube,
I can say that, you are like-
- You are, it's not
even a subjective thing,
it's like, objectively you are an OG.
- You are the OG of YouTube,
but also you are now the
interviewer of YouTubers
and now we're interviewing you.
- We're gonna reverse
engineer this interview.
(all laughing)
- My stuff is so different,
when I came here, I was like,
"So what are we talking about today?"
You're like-
- I dunno.
(all laughing)
- We'll figure it out!
- When I go into mine I'm like,
"Okay, okay, I've got like
this 45 bullet points,
I know where to get through these."
I over-plan so much.
- That shows, that shows though,
it's good, it reflects in the qualities.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah,
it really, really shows.
- My favorite stuff is always the stuff
that comes out of stuff
that happens in the moment
that was never planned,
and that is your whole show!
- Yes!
That's Trash Taste, baby!
- That's your whole show!
- That's Trash Taste, baby!
- Yeah, on YouTube it'll
say top moment, all of it.
- All of it.
- 'Cause it kinda hit me when
you came in, you were like,
"So what are we talking
about today, guys?"
And we just look at each
other and we were just like,
- What do you mean?
- "Uh, shit, we're
talking to Anthony today,
fuck, he's the interviewer
and we don't have any
interview questions."
- I was like, "Do they have
some kind of secret thing
that they're not telling me,
some kind of prank that they're gonna do?"
They're like, "Should we tell him?
No."
- We're gonna hit you with a
low blow in about 30 minutes.
- Just grill me.
- So actually, I've always wondered,
how much prep do you
do for your interviews?
'Cause as we've just
established, we do zero,
zero prep here.
(Anthony laughing)
- The only prepping we do is,
who are we getting on today?
- Yeah, let's see.
So the show starts,
I call it I Spent A Day
With, whatever the topic
or whatever the person's name is.
And at first it was like four people
that I would sit down with
and it would amount to like, eight hours.
Now it's a little bit shorter,
like two to three hours,
if it's just one guest,
a little bit longer,
but I do a pre-interview call
which is like an hour,
hour and a half or two,
and then I work backwards
to try to figure out
what questions I'm gonna come up with
based on the things that we talked about.
So, God, I cannot even quantify.
- It's a lot of prep.
- What made you start
doing pre-interviews?
is it 'cause you maybe had
some guests somewhere you're like,
"Fuck it, I could have
done way better job"?
- A little bit of that.
It was also bringing on guests
that have really big stories
and I felt like I couldn't
just go in there and be like,
"So, tell me about your childhood?"
And they just go and I'm like,
I think they probably got everything.
Also I realized that in the interviews
I was cutting out a lot of stuff.
I was like, it's a lot of me
trying to figure out where this is going.
I kind of wanna have an idea
of where we're going first.
And I realized that I was like,
every night before the
next day was an interview,
I would be up until 4:00
AM, like 12 hours straight,
like shit, I don't know
what I'm talking about!
I gotta learn every single thing
about this person's life, drill down.
I interviewed VTubers,
that's actually how I found
out about this podcast.
I saw you had interviewed
a VTuber as well.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, Calli, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
And I watched that episode
and I was learning
everything about VTubers
and I was like, wait, I
could just talk to them,
have them tell me the important things,
and then I could reverse
engineer the questions
based on the conversations
that they want to have.
- So basically you take out
some of the research time
where you don't even
know if you're going down
the wrong rabbit hole.
- Yes, yes.
- And instead you just come
straight from the source, I guess.
- Yes, and then I'm able to use
the extra time that I now
have during the interviews
to kind of drill in deeper to like,
the psychology behind the
feelings that they were having
and what things affected
them from those moments
and how they affect them now.
And I guess it just allows me
to get a little bit deeper
with the conversations.
- So the interviews are
like 20 to 40 minutes,
how much source footage do you have?
How much of it gets
cut out, do you reckon?
- Yeah, so it depends the person.
Markiplier we shot like
two hours and 40 minutes
and we cut it down to a half
hour, somehow, miraculously.
After it came out, he was like,
"Holy shit, you did it, you bastard!"
(all laughing)
But we apparently were able to get
all the key components,
the conversations that were really meaty,
have 'em in there while
cutting out all the fluff.
And it's a lot of, there's a big process.
We have five editors now.
It goes from person to person,
they all have a very specific,
they're like a specific
cog in the machine.
And it's a lot of just grinding it down.
It goes to the first person,
they get the full 2 1/2 hours of footage.
They cut it down to 50 and then it's like,
that person takes it and cuts it down,
and each person's really
good at refining the element.
- We just have a one-man machine.
(Garnt and Anthony laughing)
He works like 10 people's work.
He's just like, "I'll do it to myself."
- Yeah, damn, props to you!
- I do have a solution to that problem.
If you're coming in with
like, 2 1/2 hours of footage
and having a hard time cutting it down,
have you ever thought about
this thing called a podcast?
- You mean just releasing it all unedited?
(Garnt laughing)
- Have you ever thought about no cuts?
- I have thought about
that, and people have asked,
they're like, "Come on,
just release the full thing,
I know you got it there somewhere!"
But I feel like I'm too
much of a stickler for like,
I want it to really be polished.
I want everything that I come
out with to feel polished.
And I know there's an environment
where people want longer
conversations that are unedited,
like this one obviously
has a huge audience.
Even on YouTube where I feel like people
are not generally looking
for very long uncut things,
you guys found that audience,
it clearly does exist.
But I really want something
that feels a little bit more bite-size.
- But you could take those parts
that you cut out for example,
turn it into a compilation,
release it on like, Patreon
for a behind the scenes,
have you though about doing that?
- For sure, for sure.
We definitely have a bunch
of archived conversations
that we are noting, this
didn't really make the cut,
but it is still a strong conversation.
- I mean, with the amount of
questions I guess you're asking
and the amount of people you're asking,
I'm sure there's moments
there where you're like,
that question didn't go down great
or that was a little awkward,
let's just cut that out.
- A little bit, well, it depends,
sometimes the awkward questions
and answers have like-
- [Connor] Are the best ones.
- Yeah, are the best ones
because it puts me on the spot
to come up with something
that was unplanned,
and I overthink everything
that I usually do
that it's the unplanned stuff
that actually gets out of
my head 'cause I'm actually
there in the moment.
- That makes sense.
- But yeah, sometimes
I just move right on.
- You're like, "All right, next question."
- Sometimes we'll keep
it in of me being like,
"So anyway, uh," me not
knowing where to go with it,
like when I interviewed dominatrixes
and some of the details that they said.
I don't think there was any response
that would've felt
appropriate in that moment
about some of the actions that
went down behind the scenes.
I think I'm a little too vanilla
to have been prepared for some of that.
- Is there a lot you have
to cut out to, let's say,
keep within YouTube guidelines?
- I mean, to a certain degree, yes.
Sometimes we just censor
it and that's enough
because we don't want
the video to be age gated
and then it's like, no
one sees this video.
- Right.
- I mean, certain episodes, yeah.
"I spent a day with STRIPPERS,"
"I spent a day with DOMINATRIXES,"
I mean, I'm gonna have
an upcoming episode,
"I spent a day with PONY PLAYERS."
Look it up, actually, or maybe not,
maybe with a private
browser, incognito window.
- What is a pony player?
- So they are people that,
it's basically role play.
It's a little bit of dom and sub dynamic
and they dress up as a pony,
kind of in a leather outfit.
- Like My Little Pony or?
- (laughing) No.
- Or just like an actual pony?
- Think about a human, oh, here we go,
we got some visuals for you here.
Can you click on that
black and white one there,
I think that one's a pretty good dynamic.
Yeah, let's let's zoom in on that.
Let's take a look.
- Oh, wow.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Joey] Moving on, put these off.
- It's like a leather furry a little bit.
Except it's BSM, so it's not a furry
because those are not always associated
with anything sexual.
- Who's scouting this stuff for you?
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Do you have a dude who's like,
"Anthony, you won't
believe what I just found?"
- I mean, a little bit, yeah.
It's my producer, Elise,
she's like, "So we got this
really interesting person.
She has an arena where
horses usually reside in,
but it's for pony players.
Do you wanna add on a little segment
where you go on location?"
I was like, "Yeah, let's do it."
I didn't know how to react to that,
but the obvious answer is yes.
- You have to do it, it's the content.
- You have to, I mean, yeah,
when I do a lot of episodes,
"I spent a day with
DOMINATRIXES," I'm like,
you have to dominate me.
That's part-
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- I'm not into this, but you have to.
- You have to dominate me.
- You just have to.
For journalistic integrity.
- So many comments are like,
"Clearly Anthony just wanted
to know what this was like,"
or like, "Clearly
Anthony's a pro with this
'cause he didn't really have
that big of a reaction."
I was like, I mean, you
know, transparently,
I wanted to learn about
dominatrixes and the scene.
I have to put myself in
it to really understand
the dynamic of why people would do this,
what do they take out of it,
what do they like about it?
- How do you battle the inner
embarrassment with that?
- You know, it's the weirdest thing.
When it's on camera,
it feels like it's for
research purposes, literally.
(Garnt laughing)
And part of the humor and entertainment
comes from me being embarrassed,
which makes me less embarrassed.
- I get that.
- Does that make sense?
- Yeah, I do videos in
Japan, similar thing.
I worked in a strip club recently.
- Yeah, yeah, I did not
see that one specifically.
(all laughing)
I saw one of them!
Are the strip clubs there different?
- Uh, yeah, a little bit, I guess.
I mean, I haven't been to any here.
- Oh, oh.
- You just tell me for research.
(all laughing)
- Research purposes!
You keep taking for research purposes.
- Now you have to be able
to answer my question later.
You must go to a strip club tonight.
- Yeah, I feel like, yeah,
when you're on camera,
it kind of gives you like a free pass
to just be embarrassment.
Not good.
(all laughing)
- I realized that the other day.
I went to this bar,
and there's this social
anxiety that's just like,
uh-uh, immediately cut off any opportunity
to feel out of my element.
So I went to this thing and I was like,
I'm just gonna push myself to do it.
I was thinking, I was like,
I could totally do this
if cameras were on me
and if it was like, I'm
talking to the camera,
I'm gonna be going this thing,
I'm gonna be uncomfortable,
let's see what happens,
and then I would be able to totally do it.
And I was trying to
reframe my mind to be like,
can I trick myself into thinking
there is a camera following me
and I'm doing this for research purposes?
'Cause I would be a pro.
I would be pro at anything there.
- There is an invisible camera.
- Go to the toilet and vlog.
- It's my invincibility.
I'm like, I could do anything
if a camera is on me.
I don't know, it's weird!
- Tell me you're a YouTuber
without telling me you're a YouTuber.
- You're just a content
creator through and through.
- It's true, it empowers you.
It feels like you have
like a pass to just do it.
- [Anthony] Yeah, yeah.
- Like, oh no, don't worry,
there's a camera on him.
Oh, okay, okay.
- Like if these cameras were not rolling
and we were all just sat down up there,
I feel like it might've taken us
an extra 10 minutes to warm up, you know?
- Right.
- Yeah.
- It's weird, right?
There's like this invigoration
you can almost feel
from being on camera.
- Yeah, because like normally,
most of my content is not on camera
and the only time I
started be going on camera
was for this podcast.
And at first I was really, really awkward
and it was just really,
really weird being there,
but then you kind of get used to it
and it kind of becomes your friend, right?
It kinda becomes like-
- Parasocial relationships.
- It kinda becomes like your excuse.
- The camera or the audience?
- Oh no, the camera, the camera!
The camera becomes like
the get out jail free card
to do shit you wouldn't
normally do, right?
- That's true, that's true,
because part of the entertainment factor
comes from whatever happens.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So you're forced to lean into that.
- Yeah, and people around you as well,
as soon as they see you
being filmed, they're like,
okay, they can be a bit
of a monkey or whatever.
- You absolutely get a free pass.
- I'll tell you what is
the real free pass though.
So sometimes in Japan we
bring the camera crew,
but for some reason, every
time we've brung a boom mic,
that is when people around us
know that shit's going down.
- Because they see like a
shotgun mic, they're like,
oh, well, this is just
like a hobby for someone,
there just filming for
their friends or whatever.
But when they see a massive boom mic,
they're like, oh, this real shit!
- That's professional.
- They got a crew.
- Excuse me, gentlemen,
do you want some coffee?
What do you need on set?
Thank you very much.
- They nearly think we're more important
than we actually are the moment
when they see the boom mic.
- And we don't even use it,
mostly we just use lapel mics.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's just for looks, man.
- It's just a statement.
- A get out of jail free card.
But I was thinking back to, I was like,
there have definitely been
moments of things that I've shot
that I would be so embarrassed
if the cameras weren't rolling.
And I did this video,
"I spent a day with ANIME CAFE MAIDS."
- Yeah, I saw that one.
- I've seen it.
- I saw that one.
- Okay, okay, okay.
And I said, if this video
gets over 100,000 likes,
I will become a maid and
I will make a documentary
about me doing a show,
and I actually put the show on
with the girls that I had interviewed.
And I look back at that
and I had the most
confidence in the world,
like zero bit of embarrassment
about literally stepping on people
and having my full-on ass cheeks out.
So I was like, if the
cameras were not rolling,
I would've been like, I
don't want this attention.
It was something about the
knowing the cameras are there
and almost like I'm working.
Like, I'm fucking working here, guys!
Like something about that,
I was just like, it's okay.
- It's like a little devil
that's sitting on your shoulder
being like, "Don't
worry, it's for content."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah!
(all laughing)
I don't know if that's a good thing.
- Just like a professional
through and through, you know?
It's like when you're an
actor and the director says,
fucking, what do they say again?
- Action?
- Action, yeah.
(Anthony and Garnt laughing)
- You're in LA, Garnt,
you need to know this!
- I'm sorry, okay?
I'm sorry, it's only been
five days in LA, okay?
- I feel like when I go into
a lot of the videos I'm like,
I will never get a
chance to do this again.
You could do video again,
but you can't really.
- No, no, no, it'll never
be the same reactions.
- No one's gonna click it
again, well, they will,
but you know, it's not the same.
- It's not the same, yeah.
- I was having a conversation
with someone recently
and I was trying to figure out
why I feel like I'm in
such a different headspace
when I'm conducting an interview.
I mean, mean part of it is
that I've done a pre-call,
part of it is that I know where
the conversation's gonna
go to a certain degree,
but also in many ways,
I feel like it might be,
it's like the last conversation
I'll ever have with this person.
Not to say that I'll never
talk to them or whatever again,
but for some reason there is like,
this is this one moment.
In a way it feels like
there's all this pressure.
- Like make it count.
- Yeah, and even though
there's a lot of pressure,
for some reason the fact
that it feels so dire,
it almost alleviates the
pressure in a weird way, yeah.
- Knowing that you can kind of go
for the deep questions
and really push for it.
- Yeah, like this is your one shot,
kinda like what you were saying.
- Right, right.
- That's awesome.
- When you started,
did you ever feel like,
I guess, nervous being too intrusive
or kind of like, diving
down a bit too deep?
- Yeah, a little bit.
I mean, I would tell people beforehand,
like if there's any question
that you don't want to answer,
don't ever feel like I'm trying to pry
further than you're comfortable.
I would tell them, like, tell me to not
if I'm going down in a direction
that you're not comfortable with.
But now that I do the pre-calls, again,
that removes most of that.
Sometimes I'll drill down
a little bit further,
but for the most part I
see if they're comfortable
and I try to word the questions in a way
where they can tell me
as much as they want
or go in as much as they want.
Sometimes they'll tell me something,
and if I want to get in
deeper, I'll be like,
oh, and I'll kind of rephrase
what they just said to me.
Which sounds really stupid
if we just leave it in,
it's me saying the exact
same thing that they said.
But for some reason hearing it back
I feel like they know that I understood,
and then it gives them the opportunity
to refine or dig in deeper if they want.
So usually it's like I kind of
throw out little invitations
to go deeper without
feeling like I'm prying in.
- Oh, okay.
- Right, right.
So it's like, their choice
if they would like to go down
if they want to.
- Yes, yes, exactly.
- Right, that's pretty smart to do.
- It sounded like you're
describing a different experience.
(all laughing)
- I didn't mean for it
to come out like that!
- You literally just took what he said
and explained it sexually,
like, so it's their choice to go down.
- So you're telling me it's their choice?
(all laughing)
- They don't have to.
- So like, obviously,
it's a massive interview
series on YouTube now,
but you came off of this
off the back of Smosh.
What made you want to
start doing this series?
Did you want to explore a bunch of ideas
and then this was the
one that kind of stuck,
or was it always this
that you wanted to do?
- Well, I mean, Smosh was
definitely a comedic, silly thing,
so I never thought that I was gonna get
into any deeper conversations,
like connecting with people in the way
that the series is now.
And the whole series kind
of started off as a joke.
Of course, the very
first video when I left,
I was like, okay.
Part of the joke was that I'm
an independent YouTuber now,
I have no idea what's, I mean-
- I'm a strong, independent YouTuber.
- I was feeling myself.
And it was actually very true.
I had not uploaded my own video in years
because the company had taken it over.
So part of the joke was like,
hey, what does a
independent YouTuber do now?
And I was asking for advice
and I interviewed a bunch
of popular YouTubers,
and there was something about that dynamic
of having a conversation
where I didn't know where it was going,
and the funniest moments were
the ones that were improvised
rather than 100% scripted.
And I really enjoyed that.
And then later on it
was like, let's revisit,
and I was struggling for a
long time, just floundering,
like, what do I do with this channel?
And every single week it was like,
I don't know what to do.
Okay, I figured it out.
Okay, I shot it, okay, I hate it.
So now I'm gonna figure
something else out.
Okay, I find a shot,
now I'm releasing this thing
that I don't really like,
but I ran outta time.
And eventually I was like,
what were the things
that I liked doing most
on the channel so far?
I'll dial in deeper with those ideas,
then I started expanding on it from there.
- Man, Japan needs to start listening
to how you do your interviews,
'cause you would hate how
interviews are done in Japan.
- I don't think I've ever
heard a Japanese interview.
Tell me about it.
- Oh God!
- Do you guys get interviewed on Japanese?
- No, so when did you do
interviews with anyone,
you have to give them the
exact script of the interview.
- Oh!
- And there's no room for-
- Yeah, and they will
sometimes have scripted answers
about what they will say to you back.
So everything is pre-planned.
You are not allowed to off script at all,
and it's just the most rigid interview
you could ever imagine.
- Is it like that in different
places of Asia as well?
Because I've also interviewed
someone from South Korea
and it was a similar thing where,
well, they were speaking English to me
and it was obviously not
their first language,
so it was like, of
course they want to know
what they're saying.
- That makes sense, yeah.
- They wanted the questions
beforehand and I figured,
yeah, they wanna know
what I'm saying to them
just in case a word slips
by that they don't know.
But I didn't realize what they were doing
was scripting their
responses to such a degree
that afterwards they sent me their script.
- Geez!
- Oh wow!
- I thought it was a little
bit weird in the moment
whenever I'd ask a question,
they would repeat the answer
that they had already said.
And I was like, "Hmm, okay,
well they were a lot more
loose in the pre-interview
just talking to me
about all these things,"
and then here I was like,
"Maybe they're just nervous or something.
Okay, I get it, people get nervous."
But then they sent me the
script and it was verbatim,
every single word that was said.
- Wow.
- So I think they had a teleprompter.
- Yeah, I think like,
'cause I have done quite
a bit of interviews
with industry people in Japan
and like a lot of them are like,
"Okay, send me a list
of questions beforehand,
we will approve all the questions,
we will write up a very basic thing,"
and I'm like, "Okay, that's fine."
But I've done enough
now where I'm just like,
"Okay, we'll follow your script,
but I'm gonna add extra questions."
- [Anthony] Yeah, yeah.
- "And you won't be prepared for them,
and so I can really catch you out
on what you actually feel."
And for the most part,
they're okay with it
when it actually happens.
But I think if you tell them beforehand,
"Hey, by the way, I'm gonna
throw in some extra questions,"
they'll just freak out.
'Cause they'll be like,
"We're not prepared for that."
- Their teams will say like-
- Yeah, their teams will be
like, "No, you can't do that."
But when I do it on the
day of the recording
and I get a good answer and a
good conversation flow going,
then they're like, "Oh, maybe it's okay."
- [Anthony] Yeah, yeah.
- Maybe it actually makes
for an interesting interview?
- Maybe they're not out to fuck me over.
- Yeah, exactly!
Maybe they actually are just
genuinely interested in me
and want a good interview.
- I wonder how many people
have to be screwed over
in order for that to become the standard.
- Yeah, it's like, how many bad interviews
must you have done to
need to get to that point.
- Yeah.
- But it does take a while
to kind of build up that-
- Rapport.
- That rapport
and that level of respect or
trust with people, you know?
And I've seen that too.
I have people that are
a lot more comfortable
with doing my interviews now
than I think that they
probably would've been
a couple years ago before I had really,
I don't know if I wanna
call it proven myself,
but like I guess proven
that I'm not going to
purposely and maliciously
try to defame someone
and ruin their career.
- You never really showcase even
what most people would
consider strange things.
You never really show it as like,
whoa, look at this weird thing.
You're just like, these are real people,
let's just see why real
people do what they do.
- If it is a strange thing,
I like to talk with them about
how it's a strange thing.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
- And the thing is, most
people are absolutely willing
to talk about how something
that they do is strange.
It's not like they are
so in a different world
that they think everyone should do this,
and if they think it's
weird, then fuck you,
you know what I mean?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But you've had people like that though,
right, in the past?
- In which way?
- In the sense of them
trying to prove a point
and being like, "No, you're weird
for thinking that this
is weird," kind of thing.
- A little bit, but it still
seems a little playful.
They're like, "Normies don't get this."
(all laughing)
So they still I think recognize that,
but definitely people are
a little bit defensive,
but I think it's because
they've been shown enough times
that they almost, they feel
like they have to be defensive,
'cause that means that
someone doesn't respect them
and I think it's just a lot of
like vying for respect of people.
- Do you ever find people
that, it's a different field
where you're just talking
to someone casually,
but when you're in an
interview setting with cameras,
you really have to make
them feel comfortable,
like being themselves and talking.
Did you find that a challenge
with your interviews at all,
just getting people to
be comfortable on camera
as quick as possible?
- A little, yeah, and you
bring up a good point.
I do obviously have a limited time
and I can't just spend the first
hour of the interview warming up.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I go out of my way to
really connect with people.
We have the pre-interview call,
so there's a little bit of that dynamic
where we're already laughing together
and we already are on the same page,
so there's that when they show up,
but of course, they're
a little bit more tense.
But I'll meet the guests on the street,
I'll walk them in, I'll
bring them out to the back,
we do our COVID tests and we hang out
on this park bench that
I have on my balcony
and we just chit-chat
and I get to know them
and I tell them a lot about myself.
I think that there's a method
to kind of warming people up
so that they can see
like that you're genuine
and that you you're not secretly
gonna be trying to get a one up on them.
- We should have done that.
(all laughing)
- We should've taken him out back,
let him know what's happening.
- So here's what we're about.
- Damn, Anthony just
turned up and we were like,
all right, camera's on!
- Let's go, come on, chop chop!
- Now, we used to do something similar.
We called it like, I dunno.
I dunno if it was a strat,
but the Denny's strat.
So there was a Denny's
outside of our office
and we often invite
them to lunch beforehand
to get to know them, have
a casual conversation.
But one issue we always
found ourselves having
was we'd get into a conversation
and it would just be like,
shit, this is good material, this is good!
- Yeah.
- I mean, it literally happened
the five minutes since
after Anthony sat down
and we're like, shit, let's
just not ask any questions
'cause this is good material
that we can go through now.
- Yeah, and that's part
of the challenge also.
I mean, the closer you get to someone,
the more you start connecting with them,
the more you start talking about things
that are then difficult to bring back up
and have it feel like the
first time you talked about it.
But that's what helps
having my questions already.
Because we actually go away
from those conversations
for a little while,
and then if we have a good conversation,
I'll write it down in my notes.
I'll be like, this is good,
we need to bring this back up again.
- Right.
- That's a good idea.
- Smart, we should take notes.
(all laughing)
- We should definitely take notes, yeah!
- This isn't a podcast,
we're literally just
asking for advice now.
- It's like, how do you do it?
- I could have just sent you a message.
(all laughing)
- It's like, where were
the questions, bro?
- Yeah, no, this is great.
- So we're talking about before,
like how many people you have
to like run this show now.
So how many people are
there behind the scenes
and how many did you start off with?
- Yes.
So I started off with
just two camera operators
and it was just myself
trying to figure out
what the fuck I was doing.
- Right.
- And then I slowly but surely
had new people come on to help me
and now I have 10 employees on the show.
- Wow.
- Jesus.
- Very nice.
- You know, it doesn't sound
like that big of a number
until you think about how much
everyone needs to be paid.
(all laughing)
- [Connor] That's a lot.
- Yeah, that's a lot, that's a lot.
- And there's a lot of moving parts.
I started, I took two
years of community college
and I started to take business
administration classes.
Smosh started happening 2005
and I was like, ah, fuck college.
But I realized I've actually
always been interested
in kind of managing a team and a business,
and I think it's a lot of fun, teaching.
And especially once you could teach,
like I have a head of
post, the main editor,
and I get to teach him all the things
and we get on the same page.
And then there's four people that work,
I guess below him is
how people would say it,
but that work with him.
And so I get to communicate
with one person,
he communicates with four.
So I just really enjoy the dynamic
of a whole team working together
and having it feel like
a well-oiled machine.
- 'Cause I was gonna ask,
how many people did you have at most
when you were at Smosh working?
- [Anthony] Oh my God.
- How many employees did you have then?
- It's kind of hard to say
because Defy owned Smosh
and they I think had 30
people working with Smosh
and all the side channels and
the live events and the live,
yeah, there's so many elements there
that I guess 30 was the magic number.
I don't even think I met
some of the people that
were working there.
(Connor, Joey, and Garnt laughing)
- It's like, they're there somewhere.
- It was a weird team situation
where we all never really
got to know each other fully.
- Obviously, we're YouTubers,
you see that lovely 1 out of 10 system,
which is the most
depressing system on earth
and it's very Black Mirror-esque.
- Or it's the best system in
the world when it's 1 outta 10.
- Our viewers have heard
us complain about it
like a million times,
but I imagine when you have 10 employees,
that suddenly if you're
getting a 10 out of 10
and then maybe you get a 9 out of 10,
it starts to get a lot scarier, right?
- Yeah, there's a lot more weight.
- I mean, how do you deal with that,
did you deal with it like
as a team or you like,
"Guys should leave me alone,
I'm gonna cry a moment"?
(Joey, Anthony, and Garnt laughing)
- There's still a part of
me that is affected by it,
I can't say that there's not.
And it's not even like
an outward thing of like,
ah shit, dude, what am I gonna do?
But even if I just carry on with my day,
there is like a part of me where my energy
feels a little bit like something
was pulled out from me a little bit.
Even if I'm not thinking about it,
it must be some suppression.
And then when there is like a 1 out of 10,
I'm a little, oh, my
posture's a little better.
But I've been really
working on reminding myself
that a bad video now was
actually a good video for me,
like in terms of performance.
When I first started
what I would now consider
probably a lower performing video
was a good performing video,
and we still have sponsors.
And I try to look at
what my actual progress
has been for the show,
it's not just views.
It's so easy to think views
are a measure of progress
because it's the biggest number.
When you go on YouTube,
it's attached to every single thumbnail.
In fact, many people decide
if they're gonna click on something
based on how high that number is.
You see one video and it has 10,000 views,
someone is much less likely then
to click that same video
with 10 million views
because there's that curiosity aspect of,
wait, so many people are watching this,
this has gotta be something
extraordinary, right?
- If there is a YouTube
video under 30 seconds
that has over a million views,
you know it's a banger!
- You know you're gonna click it!
- You notice that, it's
always a fucking banger!
- And that shit's gonna be
delivered to you so quickly,
30 seconds, that's it?
30 seconds to have a banger.
- Instant serotonin.
- I'm fine with that.
But, you know, that is not my only measure
of where I'm going with this.
Part of it is also like,
I want to grow respect
and have people trust
that I will treat them
with respect on the show.
So I'm having people, huge name people
have started to reach
out to me and say like,
"Ooh, I'd love to be
on the show sometime,"
and that's something
that I never had before.
So regardless of where my numbers go,
I have people that I really
respect reaching out to me
and wanting to talk with me
and have that experience
of being on the show,
and that is something that is so cool
and I could clearly see kind
of that's my metric now.
- That's impact that you're
having in the greater community.
- Yeah.
- I mean, so the whole YouTube system
and giving a shit about analytics,
was that something that I suppose
that Smosh under Defy Media
that you never concerned yourself with?
- I didn't really, because
we were just on a salary.
- Right, right, right.
- So I was like, "These
numbers don't affect me."
- Yeah, and Defy came in there like,
"Anthony, man, it's not doing too hot."
- I'm like, "Oh my God, it looks like
I have two more years, so."
- So it must have been
you were under Smosh,
then under Defy Media and
then now you're separate,
so there's probably that big gap
where you didn't really take notice
of what was really
happening on YouTube much.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Wow, that's interesting.
- So now I had to start
learning all these things.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- When did you kind of tune out of
giving a fuck about what
was happening on YouTube
or kind of not paying as much
attention and just doing-
- You mean like when I was Defy?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I'd say it was probably
around 2014 or 2015 probably
to 2017 when I eventually left
and decided to do my own thing.
I think it was the two years
that I was unhappy with
where things were going
and the way that the company was being ran
and the decisions that were being made
and how I was being left in the dark
about a lot of decisions
that were really important
that were being made.
And it was around then that I started
to just kind of tune out
from YouTube in general.
I would still put a lot of my heart
into making the things that
I was making at that time,
but there was still this part of me
that was just getting detached from it,
and that's when I kind of stopped caring
about browsing YouTube
and being part of the community as much.
- Just when you thought you were out,
you got dragged right back in.
- Yeah, yeah, I almost
made it outta the rat race!
- So do you think not caring about it
gave you more or less
freedom than you do now?
Because now you do have to
care about the algorithm,
every YouTuber has to care
about the algorithm unfortunately.
- I think it's kind of about
caring about the right things,
and by the right things,
it's not to say there's a
wrong thing to care about,
but the figuring out what
is meaningful for you
and then caring about those things.
It's so easy to start
caring about the things
that seem like they matter most,
like just straight up view count,
but then you could drill in,
you could read the comments
and see how much of an
impact a certain thing made
and you could realize that
that is more important.
So you have to define the
things that matter most to you
before you just start
caring about everything.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Damn.
- So you mentioned something
earlier just off the cuff,
but you were just like, "Yeah,
so I quit college in 2005
because Smosh was a thing."
- Yeah.
- What!
- So you quit in college
in 2005 to do YouTube?
- Yeah.
- Wow, that's super,
super ahead of the curve.
- Yeah, that was really
ahead of the curve!
You like, foresaw that shit.
- "Mom, I made one Pokemon Dollar,
I'm going, I'm quitting!"
- Basically.
(all laughing)
- I said it a little wrong.
So I went to two full semesters,
so I think it was technically 2006.
And I was signing up for classes
and I was thinking about
the amount of time,
'cause the classes obviously get harder
the further along you
get with your degree,
'cause they start dialing into
the actual difficult things.
And I was like, okay, I could be doing
all these extremely
difficult things for this,
which was now taking my time
away from this other thing
that is now starting to build,
this is a once in a lifetime opportunity.
I felt like I was almost like
the master of my own fate with this world
while I felt like
getting a college degree,
while obviously super
helpful for most people,
I felt like this is something
I can always come back to.
And also this kind of
puts me in a position
where I'm kind of following a system
that other people have
put in place for me.
I felt like I was making
up my own rules on YouTube.
- So did you foresee the fucking ecosystem
YouTube would become, or you're just like-
- Fuck, no, no!
Yeah, I'm like, "Ah, I see it all!"
- Well you were confident
enough to be like,
bye college, you know?
- Did you just have this
like, 'cause obviously,
how many videos or where
were you at at that point
when you decided to quit college?
What kinda stage was it at?
- I think we had. (laughs)
- How many?
- I think we had six videos out.
(all laughing)
- What the fuck!
- Oh my God!
- Would you ever recommend to
a YouTuber with six videos-
- No, never do what I did.
Never do what I do,
unless your parents are very well off
and they're totally fine
with you not doing college
and they wanna help you.
- How many subs did
you have when you quit?
- The subs were not a thing.
- Oh, they weren't a thing?
- They were called followers.
- Wow!
(all laughing)
They were not a thing.
But the reason that I felt confident
is because this outside company
that was competing with
YouTube called (beep),
does not exist anymore,
they reached out to us and they were like,
they gave us this contract
that was in hindsight very shitty,
but we were college kids
who were still living
under our parents' roof
and we were like, you know what?
This makes sense.
We can fund these things
that we love doing.
We just had the best time hanging out
and just laughing our
asses off, creating things.
A college kid, that's
what the college kids
really want to do most of
the time, not the homework!
- Man, you get one
paycheck and you're like,
"I am set for life!
Mother, I have a career now!"
- So we signed a two-year contract
with this outside company.
They offered us 3,600
bucks to split between us.
- [Connor] For two years?
- No, no, each month.
- Oh, okay.
- Okay, okay.
- I know, I know, I know.
It sounded worse, it's
still not great though.
So we each got 1800 bucks
and we each also invested
our own money from that
into the videos themselves,
and they also give us a
little bonus at the beginning.
So I got to like, I had
this piece of shit car,
and I couldn't do anything
'cause every time I got my car,
it would not work, anyway.
So I bought a new car and
I was like, you know what?
We have a two-year contract
here, we're pretty safe.
I could come back to do these classes
if I really need to.
- Okay, that makes way more sense.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I just did six videos.
- It was like one of the first deals
where a company was trying
to compete with YouTube
and take that audience away.
And part of their contract was this video
has to be exclusive to us for two weeks,
and after the two-week period,
you can release it to YouTube,
but it has to have a
brought to you (censored)
tag on the front and at the
end and a watermark on it.
- Oh shit.
- Still kind of generous that
they even let you do that.
- It was, but their whole
strategy for marketing
was that they were trying
to steal the audience from YouTube.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So the only way for
them to get an audience
on their platform was to let people know,
but unfortunately they
didn't have anything to offer
that was bigger than the scope
of what YouTube had to offer.
I don't need to get into
the legality behind it,
but eventually we were able
to get out of that contract
because they promised us a certain,
wow, I don't know if I should
have said that company name.
- You wanna bleep it out?
- Do you wanna bleep it?
- We can it out.
- Mudan, bleep it out.
- Okay, thank you.
Bleep out the company name. (laughing)
- So now I feel more-
- Now you go ham.
(all laughing)
- Now I feel comfortable
saying everything.
So they promised a certain
amount of marketing value
and they translated that to
a certain amount of views.
It was like some odd millions of views
they were promising to bring to our videos
on our channel on their platform.
They did not live up to that.
And when we started
getting on them about that,
we found out, I'm wondering
how much I should say.
This is how many years ago now?
Jesus, it's 16 years ago.
- Jesus!
- Maybe it's okay.
I think that everyone
there is probably in a,
I don't know, buried underground.
(Joey laughing)
What I realized they started doing
to fulfill their end of the bargain
was, well, first I noticed that we,
oh, we had a million
new views on our video
on this channel this day.
- Oh.
- Okay, so this website where our videos
usually get 5,000 views are
now getting 1,005,000 views.
There's something up here.
- Oh!
- So I go into the comments and I get,
"Fuck Smosh, what is this bullshit?
I'm trying to look at my MP3s
and why is this playing?"
I find out that they also
own this other website
and they have a little hidden iframe
that's autoplaying our videos
in the background of this other website.
- Oh shit.
- What the fuck!
- So they'd go to this website
and then they'd hear
the audio of our videos
while they're trying to fucking
browse this other website
and it would count as a view.
(Garnt laughing)
- [Joey] Oh my God!
- So eventually we were able
to get out of the contract
'cause were like, this is not very cool,
it's actually giving us a bad reputation
'cause people think
that we are doing this.
And then eventually we were
able to get out of that.
And it was at that time that both,
oh my God, MySpace was trying
to launch a video platform.
- I'm not sure if kids today
know what a MySpace is.
- No, no, it's your space.
So they were trying to
launch a video platform
and they came to us with an offer,
and then YouTube was like,
"Hey, there's this program
where you can make money on
your videos on our platform
that never had any ads before.
Would you like to be one
of the first 10 channels
to ever make any money on here?
We'll give you a guarantee."
And even though they're
guarantee was lower than MySpace,
thank everything in the world,
we said, "Yeah, we'll stick with YouTube."
And that's kind of where
everything started,
that was early 2007.
That's when we-
- Was that just like, were
you guys just guessing
or did you genuinely feel like,
I think YouTube's gonna be the king?
- There was this feeling.
Also we had a video on there,
our "Pokemon Theme Song" lip sync video.
(all laughing)
- Absolute classic!
- The classic!
- Classic tune.
- It's like "The Godfather."
You go to like the IMDB
page of YouTube videos
and that's like at the top.
- Top 100 YouTube videos, it's up there.
- Now, it would be if
there was an IMDB for-
- In our brains, in our brains.
- So that video I think had
something like 25 million views.
- [Joey] Jesus Christ!
- And it was easy to see that the market,
the viewership was on YouTube
and they had just been purchased by Google
for way too cheap,
which is still billions of dollars.
And I felt really good about Google,
I felt good about where they're going.
Even though I met Tom from MySpace myself,
I was like, hmm, Google.
- You met the creator of MySpace?
- Yeah, yeah, briefly.
- What was he like?
- He was just a dude,
I mean, I don't know.
A dude wearing a nice jacket.
- Did you do the this thing?
- He did not.
I feel like everything
within him was like,
"I can't do that.
I can't even give a thumbs up or a smile."
No, no, he was a good guy.
- Did he add you on MySpace?
- We were already friends, bro!
(all laughing)
- But was he in your top eight friends?
That's the real question.
- He became part of my top eight
after I thought I might
have a deal with him.
- Oh shit!
(all laughing)
- My top eight business friends.
- I'm like, shit, if he goes
on my page he's gonna know!
(all laughing)
Oh shit!
I think he does photography now,
and he's a good photographer.
But anyway, so I went with
YouTube, we went with YouTube.
Ian and I made the decision
to go with YouTube there
and obviously it was the right choice.
It just felt right, you know?
- So you were getting paid even before
there was even an economy on
YouTube or anything like that.
- The funny part is that all they were
was the lower third ad,
the little tiny thing that
pops up at like 15, 20 seconds.
And even then, we were afraid
of the backlash that
we might get for that.
- That's so funny.
- We enabled it on our older videos
and then the newest video we waited
till like our bigger
audience came in and left
so that we wouldn't get flak for it.
And even on our older
videos, people were like,
"Whoa, you fucking sellouts!"
(all laughing)
It's an ad where you go your mouse,
no one's one's on mobile,
you're on your computer,
and all you have to do is move
your mouse and click the X.
And people are like, "ugh, fuck this!"
- That's one extra step I have to do!
- Now people watch videos and
there's a minute and a half
unskippable ads six times in a video.
- And whenever a YouTuber
gets sponsored they're like,
"yes, king, make that money."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, but no.
- Did you get backlash when
you had your first sponsor?
'Cause I feel like
YouTube ads are one thing.
- Every YouTuber did I think.
- Oh, you mean Smoothie King?
- Was that what it was?
- Was that your first sponsor?
- That was our first sponsor,
it was called Smoothie King.
It was this like, I don't
know if they're independent
or if they're a chain,
but they're a smoothie
place in Austin, Texas,
or, I forget, somewhere
in Texas, I don't know.
And yeah, we just had to
make a little video there
and put it out,
we didn't even put it on our main channel,
our second channel,
They paid us like a couple
thousand or something,
and it was like, you know,
that was our first sponsor.
- Was the reception to that though?
- What the fuck is this?
(all laughing)
- YouTube seems so wild.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Weirdest shit.
- There were absolutely no rules.
And I remember when I first started,
I would actually go out
of my way to break rules
to show YouTube that this
rule could be broken.
I'm just a bad boy.
- Like what?
- And one thing that I realized
is that there was this channel that,
I can't remember what the name of it was,
in fact, it's probably better
that I don't say the name.
They had videos that would just pop off,
but they'd have like, 12 comments.
And I was like, this math doesn't add up.
And of course, as an 18-year-old kid,
I was like, I must get
down to the bottom of this.
It's my duty!
- Internet detective mode.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So I did a test on our MySpace
and it was kind of what I learned
from that other company doing
the hidden iframe thing.
So I realized on MySpace you
can hide an iframe as well.
Which is ridiculous to think
that anyone could have any
page load in the background.
So I hid it on our page and
I realized that that worked.
So I said, "YouTube, fix this."
I don't know if it was even me saying it,
but also a big thing was that that channel
was also having hundreds of
thousands of new subscribers.
I think it was right when
they announced subscribing.
And I was like,
how is this channel that
gets so little comments
having so many views and subscribers?
So I also hid an iframe on our MySpace,
that auto-subscribed
people to our channel.
And after a day, I was like,
"Ee, yeah, this is gross,
I'm not gonna have this on here."
So I removed it, we got like
100, 200 new subscribers,
I felt gross about it.
And I think in order
to repent for my sins,
I went to YouTube and I was like,
this is a way that people
are cheating the system.
So then YouTube within
the next couple days added
on the subscribe page that
had a little button that said,
are you sure you want to subscribe?
- Was that back when you
could actually talk to YouTube
and get through to them?
- Yes, yes!
Especially if you had a
big audience on YouTube,
it was like concierge service.
- Really?
You just kind of get shit done?
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Wow.
- We went and hung out in, I
don't know, I don't remember
I don't know San Bruno,
San Jose, some San,
near San Francisco,
and hung out with people
there that work there.
And then Chad Hurley, Steve
Chen, the creators of YouTube.
- [Joey] Damn, dude!
- We just don't have enough subscribers.
- Think of the good old days, right?
- It was so rare though for
people to have an audience,
because most people that
uploaded videos to YouTube-
- One-off viral clips and stuff.
- Were one-off viral clips,
so it was very rare for
people to have audiences
and have recurring videos
of a specific channel.
So I think that they really
treated everyone back then
as like their gems that
were making YouTube
be something bigger.
- 'Cause I remember back in the day
it was just like you would
go on the most viewed,
you go on like the most
viewed of all time,
and obviously the Pokemon
lip sync was there,
then you have like "Evolution of Dance."
- Dude, ah, classics!
- Fucking "Charlie Bit My Finger."
- Classics!
- Classics.
- The classics, you know, the classics.
- Because I always forget, at one point
you were the most subscribed
channel on the platform.
- Yeah, yeah, two separate times.
- Two separate times, yeah.
- It was like a three-month period
and a eight-month period
or something, I forget.
- How was that?
How was it at that at one
point you were at the top?
- It was really cool.
- Was there pressure though, I bet?
- There was definitely pressure.
And it filtered the way that I looked at
everything that I did for better or worse.
There was the good of like,
ooh, everything that I make
has some kind of value,
I should put a lot of my
time and energy in this
'cause I know a lot of
people are gonna see it
and it really pushed me to constantly
be pushing myself outside my boundary
or out of my comfort zone
because I knew that it
would, not literally pay off,
but it would pay off in the sense
that a lot of people would see it
and potentially be able to enjoy it.
But then on the opposite side of that,
there was a lot of getting in my own head
about the pressure and how
I have to live up to this.
And then you're also
always seeing comments
of people saying like,
how is this, whatever,
and it's a lot of filtering
it out to be like,
it doesn't matter that some
people don't like this,
it's not for them,
but it would get in my head of like,
oh, I need to be better
and it was a lot of like
this, this pressure.
- You were mentioning earlier
about how obviously when you started,
you got a deal from a company.
- Yeah.
- I imagine when it
was starting to ramp up
and get to number one most subscribed,
you're probably getting offered
all sorts of weird and predatory stuff
and just probably just the most stressful
company meetings ever.
- Dude, we had someone
show up to my house,
I was living with my mom, obviously,
like in just our small little, tiny house
outside of Sacramento, California.
And there was this predatory,
I don't wanna call him predatory,
but there's this guy came
up in a business suit
and he's like, knocked on the door.
My mom was like, "There's
someone outside to see you."
- Oh no!
- So Ian and I walk out and
we're like, "What is up?"
And he is like, "Oh, I got your address
because I saw that you just
registered for a business
and it was marked under this address,
so I figured I would just show
up and tell you a few things
about what you could be doing,
- What the fuck!
- how you could be monetizing this."
And I was like,
I was 18, so I didn't know,
and it was my first time
with any kind of fame
or notoriety or anything.
I didn't know that this was
a fucked up thing to do,
so I entertained it-
- Come on inside.
- Would you like some tea?
- Okay, I drew the line there,
I didn't invite him inside,
there was no invitations inside.
But luckily he was a vampire
and he could not enter
without me inviting him in.
No, so he was like, "Okay,
so your "Pokemon Theme Song" music video,"
(all laughing)
like it's this epic
piece of cinematic work.
And he was like, "It has 3 million views,
so think about it this way.
I could get you sponsored by Coca-Cola."
- Oh my God.
- "And if you get $1,000 per million,
that gets $3,000 in
your pocket like that."
And I was like, "First of all,
do you have any contact with Coca-Cola?"
And he just started listing it all
and I realized immediately
that he was full of shit,
he was trying to make
some kind of a connection.
And he was like, "But then McDonald's,"
and I was like, "dude,"
so he clearly didn't know
what he was talking about.
Luckily he only showed up
one other time after that.
- Only one other time!
(all laughing)
- This one other time I was like,
"Mom, when that guy shows up again,
you just ignore that man.
The bad man in the suit, leave him."
But luckily we were, I mean,
we were not very smart,
but we were smart enough to know
that that did not feel right.
- 'Cause we were talking to Sean,
Jacksepticeye, a few weeks ago
and how back in like the
early days of YouTube,
there was just no boundaries
between fans and the creator,
so fans would literally
show up at his house.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Did that happen to you a lot?
- Oh, absolutely.
- Yeah, yeah, so Ian and I ended up
renting this place together he and I,
and we had another roommate with us too,
and we lived there for I think four years,
and that's when our videos
were really, really, really
starting to become popular,
like 2009 to 2011-ish.
And there's so many ridiculous stories
of like, mobs of people,
I'm trying to edit in my editing room
and I just hear people
running around the house
and laughing and looking
through our trash.
- What the fuck!
- What!
- People did not know boundaries.
- How did they find out where you live?
- Because we were really stupid.
(Connor, Joey, and Garnt laughing)
So all blame is on us,
but we would just shoot
outside of our house,
our address would be in
it, our cross streets,
like they knew exactly how to find us.
- Because this was also during the time
where you were doing the mail unboxings
on the second channel, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- So I bet that also came
into it as well, right?
- I remember like, back way
back when I used to watch
those mail unboxings.
- Oh yeah?
- Those were my favorites,
I love those videos.
- Dude, those were so wild!
- I think at that time it
was something so unique
because obviously you know
big, massive celebrities
would be getting this kind of stuff,
but I think it was the first
time that a normal person
could just watch somebody
receive all sorts of weird shit.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And it was just like, this is so weird.
- It really did show you
the scope of how strange
the common person can be
with the items that
they choose to send you
and the drawings that they choose to draw.
- That must have been weird.
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
- What was some of the weirdest
stuff you ever got sent?
- I have some very good go-tos
for that, don't you worry.
- Okay!
- We got it, yes!
- Yes!
- We we got Ziploc bag of dead bees.
- (laughing) What!
- I wanna know, how did
they collect those bees?
- They might not have been bees.
Maybe they look like bees,
I did not examine enough to know for sure.
We have a slightly smaller,
thinner bag of nail clippings.
- [Connor, Joey, And Garnt] Oh!
- Didn't you receive shit
as well at one point?
- We received stuff that smelled like shit
that we never ventured into.
(Connor laughing)
- You didn't play with it?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, I felt the texture.
It's like, "This is
definitely elephant shit."
- Gave it a little smell?
- It's definitely human shit.
- We definitely had boxes,
and we received so many
boxes that we would sometimes
just throw it in our garage
and they would sit in
the humidity and the heat
and it would be months
before we'd get to it.
And people thought it was so funny
that they would send us sandwiches.
And these sandwiches
were just rot and mold.
- Oh, 'cause of like the
food fight stuff, I imagine.
- I don't know of why,
but it became a thing.
And the bags, the Ziploc
bags would inflate
with the gases from these
things and they would pop,
and then the scent would just permeate
throughout our entire house.
- Oh God.
- Yeah, you you'd throw away the boxes
once they were kind of-
- You could see like, patches?
- Kinda sopping wet or oily or greasy.
But that quickly was like,
it's probably about time
to stop receiving the mail.
Like, it was fun, it
was a great time period.
- So how long did you guys do that for?
- I think we did it for
like three or four years.
- Oh my God!
- Yeah, yeah.
- Was your garage just fucked?
- And by the end it was
years of stuff just built up,
towers and towers of mail.
- Oh my God.
- But like you said, every now and then
you probably get something
really fucking cool
that you're like, yeah, this is sick.
- Yeah, we would receive
some really cool shit.
- Lots of used video games
and then I would just
take 'em all the GameStop
and I'd be like, "Used video games."
(Connor, Joey, and Garnt laughing)
And then they'd be like, "$100 credit."
I was like, "Two games I actually want."
- That's so big brain, I
didn't think about that.
- Not like the eight copies
of the Nintendogs ripoffs
of like Puppiez and like all these weird,
like Ponyz and Catz with a Z,
so many weird games that I
would never be interested in,
I was like, I can convert
these into games I wanna play.
- Is it just people giving junk?
Are they just trying to get rid of it?
- Well we were given,
a lot of stuff that we
were given were just like,
people were looking for things to send.
- Yeah, like I want to send you something.
- And they didn't wanna
spend money on just sending,
'cause they didn't even
know if we would see it.
There was no guarantee,
we didn't even know if we would see it.
In fact, some of the things, I hope,
it's probably better off we didn't see
half of the things that we did see,
but people would send us just old stuff
that they wanted to throw away.
- Should've started a garage
sale or something, right?
- Yeah, it was like old shirts
that had not been washed in
years and had holes in them.
- Yeah, because to them,
it was probably just like,
"Yo, that's my shirt is the video!"
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yes, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So then we had to start
being really selective
about the things that we showed.
We had to stop showing the shit stuff,
the dead stuff, the human body remains.
(Joey laughing)
- The human bodies.
- Anything that came from a human body
was no longer making it in the videos
up to a certain point.
We realized that we were encouraging it.
And then we out also
accidentally encouraged people
to send us money,
because we had one
video where a few people
sent us like $1 bills.
So he's like, "Well we got 10 bucks!"
And it was kind of a joke.
And then we had to make a,
"Woo, we got 100 bucks!"
And then it was like,
we need to stop showing money altogether.
And we realized that
anything that we showed
was a direct call for people
to send us more of it.
So eventually we had to
stop showing the weird stuff
or the really grandiose stuff
'cause we didn't feel
comfortable with either.
- Yeah, someone might
feel bad if you show off
something really amazing and they're like,
"Oh, and I guess shout-out from Mexico,
sent me this like shitty like keyring."
- And a lot of people were
sending really sentimental
handwritten things that
we could never actually,
like, if I wanted to
read every one of those,
and I really wish I could
'cause they were so heartfelt,
it would've been a
full-time job to do that
instead of anything else.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Which is a great problem to have.
- I'm interrupting this
episode of Trash Taste
to give you an important announcement.
This Trash Taste episode
is sponsored by Bokksu.
Anyone who watches Trash Taste will know
that we are big fans of Bokksu.
If you haven't heard of it yet,
Bokksu is a monthly
subscription snack box service
that delivers premium Japanese
snacks and tea pairings
straight from Japan to your door.
The first box who you receive
is called Seasons of Japan.
Following the seasons of Japan,
you'll receive a new monthly themed box
every single month, like this one.
This one's theme is,
doo-doo-doo, oh, Onsen Vacation.
You know me and the boys
are always talking about
our onsen vacations.
And this theme, you can
get snacks from places
that are famous for their onsens.
Each Bokksu is packed with snacks
and it comes with a cultural booklet
that tells you all about the theme,
where the snacks come from,
details on all the flavors,
and it even teaches you a few
Japanese words and phrases.
Baka.
Now, I would like to try, oh yes!
Osenbei.
It's a rice cracker
snack and I love these!
Mm!
So if you wanna try some
rare Japanese snacks
and support Japanese family businesses
and support our channel,
make sure to go and order a Bokksu
by smashing that link in
the description down below.
And don't forget to use
coupon code TRASHTASTE15
to get $15 off your
very first Bokksu order.
Back to the episode.
- So you mentioned like,
you were pretty much one
of the first creators
to get paid for doing
what you do on YouTube.
When did you start to realize,
oh, this is serious now,
this is like gonna get big?
- I mean, it depends,
there were so many
different levels of big.
Like at that point I already
felt like it was a big thing.
'Cause I was like,
we are one of the first people
to get paid on this platform
that I foresee as having longevity.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But in terms of like, I don't know,
it was a little bit dicey though.
So that was 2007 and
then four years later,
I didn't really know what the
fate of YouTube was gonna be
and we had an offer from a
company which ultimately,
their name ended up being Defy,
and they offered us then to
buy our company for stock.
Totally great idea.
- Well, you've talked about this a lot
in your video about it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Obviously didn't end up
being worth anything.
- So how did they pitch it to you
in a way that you both were like,
"Yeah, this is a fucking
great idea, let's do it."
Like how did that happen?
- Yeah, and it is a
complicated process too,
because the state of YouTube in 2011,
it felt really like we didn't
know where it was going.
- Was that before or
after the Google+ thing
they tried to shove in?
- No, that was when I first started,
so that was like 2014.
- Yeah, yeah, that that was ages after.
- Okay, okay, okay, 'cause that
just felt like everyone was-
- That was shit, that was shit!
- Google+ is when Google
tried to do Facebook and-
- Oh yeah, I forgot about that.
- That was just a shit
show when it came to it.
- I think it lasted like a year maybe.
- Then they cut it.
- And then they were like,
nah, we'll get rid of it.
- I get it though, YouTube
has been constantly,
especially into earlier days,
it did seem like it was like,
what the fuck is-
- It felt very fragile for a while.
Yeah, so they presented it to us as,
we're gonna take all the website,
Smosh.com stuff off your plate,
because I was doing all of that myself,
because I actually made money
before we started getting paid on YouTube
by designing websites for people.
And that's how I was able
to fund a lot of things
and, you know, side tangent,
our videos actually started getting,
we made like two lip sync
videos before the Pokemon theme.
(all laughing)
- If it works it works, baby!
Keep it coming!
- Doing a little test run!
- Before we found out about YouTube
and I hosted it on my own website.
Because there was no website
like YouTube to host it on.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And I created a little thing,
again, it was an iframe
you copy-paste there,
and when you paste that to your page,
it had instructions and everything,
when you copy-paste it
to your MySpace page,
it put the video there
and then it also had instructions
to copy and paste for someone else.
That was how I designed this
copy-paste viral kind of thing.
And I didn't know how well that was doing
with the two lip sync videos,
it's so weird to say that,
that we did beforehand,
but I did get the bill,
I did see the bill and it was
a couple hundred bucks, you know?
And I didn't know how to convert that
into how many views this was getting,
but I knew it was getting a lot of views
or else I wouldn't have to pay
a couple hundred dollars
for bandwidth on videos.
So you actually used to
have to pay for bandwidth
before YouTube offered the service.
So we found out about
YouTube by me doing a search
for one of the videos I found
that someone else had
uploaded it to YouTube
and I sent 'em a message.
I was like, "Hey, this video,
thank you so much for uploading it here.
We wanna upload it ourselves.
Do you mind removing it?"
And they said, "Yeah, absolutely."
So we created our
channel, Smosh was still,
five letters, still available,
and that was the beginning of that.
- Damn.
- Shoot, I forgot where we were going.
We were going with why Defy was-
- Why did Defy, like how
did that all come around?
- How did they pitch it to you?
- Yes, okay, okay.
Yeah, okay, I got off on a side tangent
'cause I was talking about
how I designed the website.
- Trash Taste is all about
tangents, don't worry.
- You're fitting right in, right in.
- Yeah, oh yeah, seamless.
So they came to us and they were like,
we will take care of the website
so you no longer have
that stress to deal with,
'cause every week the website was crashing
and I was figuring out how to keep it up.
And they had this huge plan
of all the things that
they were capable of
and how they had the infrastructure
to allow us to do all of our dreams.
So they asked us,
what do you want to do with this company?
If you could make this company
anything, what would it be?
And we had these huge lofty goals.
They said, we got all of that on lock.
We have the infrastructure,
we have the investors,
we could make this happen
and they offered us a certain
amount of money in stock.
Sounded really good,
more money than I thought
that I would ever see
in my life before that.
So I was like, that sounds great.
Obviously this company's
eventually gonna go public,
that's how they work, right?
I did not know.
My lawyer did not tell me that
that's not always the case.
The people that we had surrounding us
that were authority figures
in some way to us on the situation
did not break down the details
of how that doesn't always happen
and how that's actually a huge risk.
- [Connor] Yeah, yeah, of course.
- So they bought full ownership
and they paid us in annual salaries.
And they had this structure set up
where it was like this year,
eh, it's pretty shitty salary,
but next year it's an okay salary.
But by year four, you're
gonna love your salary.
- Did that happen?
- It did eventually play out that way
and I was pretty comfortable with it.
I was like, we are making
a good salary here,
what do we really have to complain about?
- And I guess they're
doing a lot of the stuff
that you used to have to do
and they're looking after
things and managing it.
But then also imagine as a YouTuber,
it's probably quite difficult
to give that control to someone else.
- It was too, because did
give that control away
and everything was not
how I would've done it.
So I ended up working double time
to teach them how to do the things,
but then they were rehiring.
And the way that bigger companies work
is it's like you're never just building
a one-on-one relationship with someone
who you teach 'em once and they know
and they keep going with that thing
and then it's just a
thing that happens now.
It's like, no, you're reteaching
and reteaching and
reteaching until it's like,
okay, let's abandon the website.
And then it was like me
abandoning a lot of the things
that I had a dream of growing
because I was not able to keep that up
and also do the videos.
I had to figure out where to put my time.
- Yeah, was there a specific point
when you kind of realized,
damn, this is not what I envisioned at all
and I kind of want out?
Was there a specific moment or was it just
a buildup of a lot of things?
- It was primarily a buildup
over a long period of time.
It was about four years in when I realized
that things just weren't looking right
and I still had two years
on the contract left.
And I think one particular thing was like,
they hired someone that I did not know
that they were gonna hire,
and then all of a sudden I found out
that they were now a full-time employee
in this really important position
that meant something to me and I was like,
"Wait, I didn't realize that
was what was gonna happen."
And also there were times,
and I don't know how much I could say,
but I'll see what I can do. (laughing)
- Well, they don't exist anymore.
- True, technically.
There was a fundraiser that they put on.
It was for a game,
and they had just seen the
success of other people
who had done fundraisers for games,
Indiegogo, GoFundMe type things,
and they raised like
$250,000 for these games,
which were like mobile games
but you could play it on the computer
and it was like this really cool thing
with all these inside
jokes from the community.
And they said, "Oh, that's
cool, guys, you do that."
And then we were like,
"We don't have a concept for a game."
They're like, "Ah, we'll
figure it out later.
Just raise some money."
- They just made the fundraiser
and then they were afterwards
they were like, make the game?
- And we said we need to have
something to pitch to people.
And then they're like, "Cool,
just tell 'em the idea then."
And then they're like, "You
come up with the idea."
So I came up with the idea,
Ian of course also, we
both came up with the idea.
And they were like, "Cool, you
got the idea, let's do it."
And I was like, "We need
to have concept art,
we need to show a build of the game,
we need to be able to show
what we want to do with this thing!"
And they're like, "Ah, we don't have time.
Okay, we'll get concept art."
So all we were able to do was
launch with this concept art.
- Wow.
- Oh my God.
- And launching a campaign, asking people,
incentivizing your fans to give you money,
it did not feel right to me,
but I felt backed up into a corner.
I think that's probably one of the things
that I regret from my time there,
is allowing myself to feel
backed up into a corner,
to accept money from
people that were excited
about this thing being built.
Of course, we did accept money for that
and I did put all of my heart and soul
into making it as good
as it possibly could be.
Still didn't live up to my expectations
and I feel like if it was done
the right way it would've.
But the moment that really stood out to me
was there was some shadiness about
obviously the way that they pushed
to earn money for something
because they saw dollar signs.
- Right, not because
it was a good project.
- Rather than it being
like, those types of things,
if you're gonna have
your audience fund them
it should really be a passion project.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- Exactly.
- And I could have made a passion project
'cause I really was excited about it,
but it was so forced and rushed.
And then there was some shady stuff
about like the way
that they contributed to certain donations
to inflate the way that
certain things looked,
and that's really all I'll say about that.
But it made me feel so weird about it,
I was like, I need out
as soon as possible.
- I imagine when they were
doing stuff like that,
the confidence you had in the company
was probably a bit like,
okay, if they're willing to do this stuff
it must not be going so great.
- Yes.
And I realized that the
way that they treated that
was the same way that
they were treating me
and all the other people.
- Yeah, 'cause a lot of people
lost a lot of money, right?
I mean, it was crazy.
- What was it?
- A lot of people lost a lot
of money, like YouTubers.
- Oh yeah, yeah, eventually.
Luckily, I wouldn't
say I foresaw anything,
but it didn't feel right
and I got out a year before
they ended up closing down.
And another thing that
really was a turning point
was I had made a Facebook page
and it was, I don't know, I
had like 500, 600,000 followers
or whatever you call
it on a Facebook page.
- Subscriber, friends!
- Friends.
- Friends, friends, yeah!
And yeah, it was Smosh Anthony.
And they were like, "Oh,
this has Smosh in the name
so we're gonna run this for you, okay?"
I was like, "Okay, yeah, yeah, sure."
And then I was like, I was kind of trying
to start to silently transition out.
I think they kind of picked up on the gist
'cause we still were
contractually obligated.
But I was like, "Can I
get my Facebook back?"
They're like, "No, it's ours."
I was like,
- Oh.
- "But I made that thing and you said
that you just wanted to run it
because you were gonna help
me post content on there."
They're like, "It has Smosh
in the name, this is ours."
- That's fucked up.
- Ooh.
- I was like, "um, okay," and
then I easily settled on that.
I was like, "Oh, okay, it's
fine, it's just Facebook.
Who cares Facebook."
And then they were like,
"Hey, can we get access to
your Twitter and Instagram?"
I was like, "no."
- No!
And then I immediately changed the name
from Smosh Anthony to Anthony Padilla.
(all laughing)
- It's like, not on my watch!
- After they asked me for access to that.
- In a way it's kind of cool
that they kind of forced
you into being like,
you know what, fuck this,
I'm just gonna go on my own.
I'm gonna fucking brand
myself, fuck these guys.
- It really got me thinking like,
could I do something on my own
outside of this brand that I had created.
And it was really sad because
I had made that brand.
- Well, Smosh is yours, yeah.
- When I was 14 years old I made that
as a little shitty website as like a forum
for me and my group of friends at school
to go on and hang out with each other.
It was really before social media,
it was like, we were either talking on AIM
or we were going on this website.
And yeah, it was sad to
kind of let that part of me,
like this baby that I had
brought into this world go.
- God, it must be nerve-wracking
trying to do something
yourself though, right?
Because as a YouTuber,
ditching your channel
which has millions and
millions of subscribers
to start to start from
the ground up again,
I think like you are one
of the first people I know,
like first big creators,
to really branch off
and try to do something
themselves with a new channel.
- And do it well.
- And to succeed.
- And there wasn't a precedent
set before that really
that you could really succeed
by doing something new, right?
- I mean, well, Fred did it.
- Oh yeah, that's true.
- Fred had another channel
and then he did his thing.
- Well, he did a few movies,
you did a few movies too.
- I did a movie, I did one too.
- How was doing a movie?
Oh man!
That was also another weird experience.
- But a part of me, 'cause
obviously, I mean, (laughing)
it's not a good movie.
(all laughing)
I was just going, fuck it,
I was trying to think of how to say it.
It's not a good movie.
- My heart, no, no!
I put my heart and soul into that movie,
it's the best movie!
- Wow, right in front of him?
- Oh my God!
This is fucked up!
- It's a part of like, you-
- We invite him onto the show-
- You invite me on here to talk
shit about my pride and joy?
- Listen, I wanna talk to
you honestly about this.
- Did you actually watch that?
- Yeah, I loved it.
- Dear Lord, wait.
- I love it in a way of like-
- You said you loved it?
- Yeah, it's a terrible movie.
- It's so fucking bad.
- It's so bad that it's good.
- But it's that amazing
part of YouTube history
where everyone had to have a movie.
- Yeah.
- YouTube for some reason was
like, make a fucking movie.
Pump them out.
Fred had fucking John Cena in his movie.
- Oh yeah, I forgot!
- Yeah.
- I completely forgot about that!
- It was just a fucking cool, weird time
where people were making
movies whereas like,
I mean, did you even want to make a movie?
What was going on with that?
'Cause I feel like there must have been
so many people trying to put their things,
trying to be like, "No, it should be this,
it should be this!
No, no, no, fuck this!"
Oh, we should get John Cena in it.
Everyone knows John Cena!"
- Oh, we got Stone Cold
Steve Austin in ours.
- Oh yeah.
- Well there you go.
"We gotta get someone from the WWE!"
- Well, I was like, John
Cena's not happening,
it's gonna be Stone Cold Steve Austin.
- Yeah, I wanna know about the movie.
Like, what was all that?
- Yeah.
A lot of people had movies going on
and a lot of people were
breathing down our neck saying,
so when are you gonna make a movie?
And we did kind of have this dream
of eventually making the movie
version of a Smosh sketch.
And we had a lot of, nothing concrete,
but like, ooh, what
would the movie version
of this look like?
If we get a million dollars,
we had some of the dumbest ideas
of like where the movie
was all Smosh sketch budget
and then we had millions
of dollars worth of money
pumped into the final scene.
(all laughing)
That was our initial idea!
- Because I remember on the Smosh channel,
this was way before the
actual movie came out.
You guys released an April Fool's video
called Smosh The Movie.
- Yeah, we did.
- Have you seen this video?
- I think I've watched this.
- This was like the first ever
April Fool's YouTube video that I saw,
but it was the first five minutes
was like the most insane quality,
like, oh my God, this looks like a movie!
And then the remaining hour and a half
was you and Ian walking
back home with no cuts.
- [Anthony] Yeah, yeah!
- And I thought, this is
the greatest thing ever!
So then when I heard that you guys
were actually making a movie,
I was like, say syke, say syke.
It's just another April Fools joke.
- I will say, for YouTuber movies,
what was the name of
the one with the ghost?
- "Ghostmates"?
- "Ghostmates," that was one
of the better YouTuber movies.
I will say, that one was good.
- That one we had a little
bit more freedom with
and in a weird way though,
we almost stripped out a lot of
like what made Smosh
Smosh with that movie.
So it felt weird, 'cause it
wasn't quite a good movie
and then it wasn't quite
a bad YouTube movie,
which is also entertaining
for its own reasons.
- I think it's 'cause you and Ian
are I think naturally very good on camera.
Compared to how some
other people transitioned
to the movies kind of thing,
I think you and Ian did that a lot better.
- Well, I think it definitely helped
that you guys were already
acting in your sketches.
- Yeah, there was a lot of that going on.
- Yeah, acting.
(all laughing)
- Acting in your sketches.
- I heard a lot about how I should
improve my acting in the comments.
- Really?
- Oh, yeah.
- 'Cause they're gonna go into
it and they're gonna be like,
you're a YouTuber, you can't act.
so even if you did an amazing
job, people would be like-
- Like stay in your lane.
- Yeah, people would be like, no.
- It would be like there's an expectation.
But with the movies, with the first one,
it was a lot of, you know, we
did have this dream to do it,
but then other people, it was at Defy.
They were like, "We
need to make this happen
and we need to make it
happen in four months."
- Four months!
- Four months?
- Okay, I'm just throwing a random number.
- Okay, I was about to say!
- But it was something too little.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, not enough time.
- It could have been six,
it could have been eight,
but I think it was somewhere
probably around six months.
- [Joey] Jesus.
- And we were like,
actually, no, I remember
it was after we got
to a point in the scriptwriting process
that they said this needs to happen
in this very short amount of time.
We're like, "We're not ready,
we're still fleshing this thing out!"
And it was a thing where we still wanted
to make our videos on YouTube,
we didn't want to give that up
'cause we felt like we
would've had to dropped that
in order to put all of our
effort into making a movie.
And they were like, "Don't
worry, we can hire this person."
And they gave us a few
options, they hired a person,
the script was not anything
like I would've wanted it to be.
It was a lot of like-
- Just someone on Fiverr.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Yeah.
- We found a guy.
- Yeah, who is this guy?
- It was a lot of like,
here's what someone who
isn't in the YouTube space
thinks our videos and thinks YouTube is.
- Was it someone who like
worked in Hollywood movies?
- It was like a Hollywood scriptwriter
who did TV series and I
think some movies as well,
and he did do some funny stuff,
but it was very much like
an out touch perspective.
And it was like, I mean,
a lot of Smosh stuff was
cringey in its own right,
but I was cringing at how out
of touch these things where.
It was like, I could not do these things.
There was this area where memes
go to die that was written
where it was like a space.
- I remember.
- Was that in the movie?
- No, no, no, wait, fuck, no, was it?
It does sound so familiar.
- You know, I think that Ian
might have talked about it
on a separate thing if
you've ever saw Ian.
- Okay, that's probably why.
This sounds so familiar.
- Or maybe he and I both
talked about it at some point,
but there was this part written
where it was like where memes go to die.
And he was like, "Tay Zonday's in there."
And I was like, "Okay, first of all,
you're trying to make us say
that these people are dead memes."
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
That's kinda fucked up.
And then also you are saying,
here's all these things
that are not in the now,
like it's just this weird period piece
that just feels too soon
to be a period piece,
you know what I mean?
- Also it might age poorly.
- It also just sounds like a
hello fellow children moment.
It's like yes, I know
memes, I know meme culture.
Well these that don't, right?
- It was exactly like that.
- Shillary Clinton, am I right?
(all laughing)
- It felt a lot like that.
And then we did a lot of rewrites
and it was still a very bad movie.
(Joey and Anthony laughing)
- Maybe that was a little too harsh.
- How self-aware were
you on set to be like,
guys, are we making a bad movie?
- I think I was half self aware.
I wasn't fully self aware.
Part of me thought,
like after a certain
scene happened I was like,
oh, that might actually be good.
Part of me did think it might
actually be a good movie
depending on the way it was cut,
depending on the way the
special effects looked.
But the way that it came together
was very much, I was like,
we were seeing like final
cuts of it, I was like,
"Okay, well that's the movie."
- Well, I mean, at least it's not as bad
as Shane Dawson's movie.
- I mean, it depends who you ask.
- No, that one was really, really bad.
- Was it?
- Have you seen it?
- I did, but I saw it
like on the premier night
where there was so much hype in the room
from all the friends and family
that it was hard to tell,
is this a funny joke or am I just
not in a good headspace right
now, you know what I mean?
(all laughing)
- You should go rewatch it sometime.
- Maybe I will.
- It's interesting, it's interesting.
- I never even tried that.
- No, no, no.
- It's not good.
- Okay, okay.
Well, it was a lot of fun though,
and I think that some elements
from the Smosh sketches
retained their Smoshiness.
- Yeah, I think it's much
easier for me to sit here
and be like, "You made a
fucking movie, you shit?"
Like I could do any fucking better,
like my movie would be good.
"Oh, you gotta make it in six," what?
I can't even spell.
- It was a weird process,
because we had trailers
and we had an acting coach
and we had the pressure of like,
this is the movie,
it was something like a
million-dollar budget.
So it was like-
- You got like, the full
Hollywood experience.
- It was the full Hollywood experience.
And we had like a writer there on set
to do rewrites in the moment if we needed
to rewrite something for time,
and there were a lot of scenes
that we had to cut for time
and they were rewritten on them.
It was such a different
experience where it was not,
like I could still go to the director,
who was Alex Winter and
he's amazing, you know?
Is he the Bill?
I forget if he's the Bill or Ted
from "Bill and Ted's Excellent Adventure."
The not Keanu Reeves, you know?
- Oh, he's the Ted I think.
- Ted, no, Bill, Bill.
- I don't know, the one that's not Keanu.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But Alex Winter's amazing
and his kids were huge fans of Smosh
so he really did want to give
it that genuine Smosh feel.
- Dude, now I feel bad,
I just called it bad.
(Joey, Anthony, and Garnt laughing)
Put all this heart and passion
and I just though it was bad.
- It was shit!
- No matter how much heart and passion
you put into something,
if there are few elements
that are slightly off,
it's gonna kind of all get
brought down to that level
and I feel like that's what happened.
There were a lot of great
things that could have been,
but then it was like,
there were certain elements
that just kind of brought it all down.
- I mean, hearing,
oh, we're gonna cut the
scene 'cause of time,
that doesn't make you
probably feel very confident.
You're like, that's not good.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But you know, a lot of times we're like,
we're gonna cut this scene for time
and we end up having this other scene
that totally actually
works fine without it,
it was like the rewrites were okay.
- Were your sketches before scripted,
so you already were
used to memorizing lines
or were you mostly improvised before?
- Yeah, yeah, they were
definitely scripted,
but usually we would like
get a take that we like
and then we'd be like, go
off-book for the final take,
and half the time we'd go
with the off-book version.
But it was a little bit different.
So Smosh videos, we would shoot
10 second clips of like, this thing.
You say this thing, you say this thing.
And when you do a movie,
they really want you to get
the full scene with this angle
then the full scene with the next angle.
- No jump cuts, no fucking jump cuts.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Continuity.
- So a lot of the acting in it
was actually me trying
to remember my lines,
and if I watch it, I'm just like,
I'm just trying to
remember my lines right now
for most of these lines.
It didn't really get past that.
And also I got in my
head a lot about like,
I don't think this is gonna be the movie
that I wished that could be.
- It would be so hard to really
turn up and give it your all
when it just doesn't feel
like it's going right.
- It was hard.
It was like, after the first day,
even though there were so many people
that had a lot of passion
and good intentions
and a lot of people that did put
their heart and soul into it,
after the first day I was like,
this doesn't feel like it's gonna be
what I thought it would be,
and then it was hard to get out of my head
and me get out of that headspace.
- And I guess you couldn't exactly
go to Defy and be like,
"Hey, quick change."
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's not like a YouTube video-
- Hey, we just shot the first day.
- It's like, this sketch
kind of isn't working,
let's scrap it and go to a new YouTuber.
Let's do a new video, you know?
- Yeah, yeah.
Well, even down to the sketches,
it was hard to say this video didn't work.
- Oh really?
- Because there was a lot of money
that was invested into it.
And we were given a
certain budget each month
and if we scrapped it, it would be like,
this is cutting into our overall budget,
let's just try to make this work.
So when that pressure starts building up
and you have all these
other eyes and voices
and budgets and restrictions,
that's when I think things
start to kind of go south
in those situations.
And that's when I started to feel like
things weren't really right.
Even though like, I could totally see
why you can't re-shoot a
sketch after you shoot it,
obviously it makes sense.
But I think if I was fully independent,
there were a lot of things
that I might have considered reshooting.
But when we have this level
where we want the
production value to be there
and we kind of reached that point,
it felt weird to go back.
I now know that you could
go back and it's fine, but.
- Back then you're like, holy shit!
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Damn.
- Would you ever want
to make another movie
with the correct amount of
time and creative freedom?
- Oh man.
- Anthony Padilla, The Movie.
- (laughs) It's just me in it!
- This is you.
- It's just him interviewing.
- Oh man.
I don't know, I don't
have any drive for that.
I have been pushing myself more
with the intros of my videos
on my channel that I do now.
It is scripted.
And I realize that a lot of the passion
that goes into me writing the words
makes it onto the camera when
I'm recording these intros.
- Yeah, of course.
- So now I'm trying to,
in a sense, maybe I'm
like reverse engineering
a way for me to learn how to act,
is by just actually giving the emotions
when I write these things
for me to actually give the emotions,
I'm like, oh, when you say a line
you're supposed to visualize it?
Oh!
- You're not just saying it.
- You don't just say the word?
- Yeah.
- Oh, that's what acting is.
So in a weird backward sense,
I feel like I am pushing myself
to learn how to act a little bit,
and maybe, it depends, it
depends, but right now, no.
- Because you've kind of done so much
in the time that you've been on YouTube.
Like, is there anything you haven't done
that you want to do
eventually down the line?
'Cause I feel like when
you just think about
even just the Smosh stuff,
it's like, you guys have
literally been at the top,
you've done everything,
you've done all the big stuff.
- Been at the top twice.
- They've been at the top twice, dude.
And you know, you've done the movies,
you've done, did you release a book?
- We released a graphic novel.
- Okay.
- Ah.
- Yeah, I had a lot of fun making it.
Most people don't even know that existed
'cause they did not market it.
But I put my heart soul
into a graphic novel,
but no actual book.
So that's something I never have-
- Is that something you'd wanna try?
Or is there something
else where you just like,
eventually I'd like to do it?
- Maybe, maybe.
I thought about putting together
some kind of coffee table book
that goes through the
different interviews I've done
and talks about the different things
that I learned from each interview,
the things that I've taken from that
and been able to apply to my own life,
the moments that stood out to me
as key things that I now
go back to and think about.
- Yeah, so an autobiography.
(all laughing)
- A little bit, but hopefully
it could be also a way
for people to learn through me learning.
That's part of why I do
the interview series now.
- I mean, to be fair,
if there's anyone who has enough material
to write a cohesive
autobiography, it's you.
- I don't know.
I feel like putting it in
the term of autobiography,
I'm like, uh, no!
- 'Cause it's a bit too self-important.
It's like you say, I know so much more
than all the other motherfuckers
who don't have books.
- It's cause we've seen the YouTubers
who have written
autobiographies, and you know-
- And they're just like, come on.
- I'm 24.
(all laughing)
This is my life.
- I struggled 12 times in my life,
and I've recognized eight of them.
- [Joey] Yeah, exactly.
- This video is sponsored by Tippsy.
Tippsy is a quarterly
subscription sake box
where you will get six
curated sake bottles
straight from Japan
to try all sorts of
pairings and dishes with.
- Guys, come on, you want
to try some new sake, right?
Come on.
- Well, why don't you guys try some out
while I give you some pointers?
- Well, luckily, Joey,
we have some custom sake boxes
that we made just for my wedding.
- Oh my Lord!
- I know.
- Get the full Japanese
experience with that.
- Actually get to use it this time.
- So the one that Connor
is drinking right now
is the Toyo Bijin.
This particular brew
gives an aroma red apple
that fades to an almost nutmeg spice.
It's a very dry sake,
said to be strong enough to kill a devil.
- That's actually quite nice actually.
- Yeah, I told you. (laughs)
- Yeah, that's good, that's good.
- What am I drinking, Joey?
- Well, Garnt, you're drinking
the Kinoene Junmai Ginjo.
The sake itself is bursting
with enticing aroma and pristine flavor
with hints of freshly sliced
apple and a crisp finish.
- That's actually really good.
So guys, if you want some
amazing deals on your sake
then you can get 10% off all products
using code TRASHTASTE10.
- And you can get $30
off your first sake box
by using TRASHTASTE30.
- Is that two coupon codes?
- That's two coupons codes,
smash that link down below.
- That is two different deals, guys.
- Smash that link.
- Back to the episode.
- I have to ask, 'cause I'm curious
'cause you've been on YouTube for so long.
Sorry, do you hate when people say that?
- No, no, no, no.
- You're such a fucking dinosaur, dude!
- I just think about my age, it's fine.
- You're YouTube boomer, dude.
- 'Cause you know,
YouTube has gone through
a lot of distinct eras, I'd say.
Do you have a favorite YouTube era
where you felt like this is
when it was peak YouTube?
- The golden time of YouTube.
- Yeah, yeah.
I think it was probably
around like 2011 to 2013-ish
where there was money to be made,
and sponsors, like people
would take it seriously enough
to fund everything,
but yet there wasn't this
idea that mainstream media had
of like, anyone can do this
and become a millionaire.
You know what I mean?
I feel like it was still very independent
and it just felt like creativity
was what thrived most.
- Yeah, because I feel
like that era of YouTube,
all of the biggest creators at that time,
they all started YouTube
not to make money,
but just because they enjoyed
the creativeness of it,
they enjoyed making videos.
And then I feel like after that,
it kind of progressed
into people realizing
that you could make this a job.
- Absolutely.
- And people did it for money.
- And it could be a business.
- Yeah, it's a legitimate business,
which is, you know,
nothing wrong with that,
but I feel like part of
the magic was lost, I feel.
'Cause it kind of transitioned
into something else, you know?
- Yeah, a different mindset
going into creating things.
And around that time or soon after
is when I think the
algorithm was introduced.
- Ah, yes.
- The elusive algorithm.
- The algorithm!
- The one god of YouTube.
- I'm learning more now that the algorithm
really does reward the things
that people enjoy consuming most,
and the algorithm's goal,
while no one individual
knows everything in and out
'cause it's made by so many
people and it's taught to learn.
That's not scary, don't worry.
- It's sentient!
(all laughing)
- It's not sentient at all.
- The algorithm does reward the things
that do have the highest retention,
that have people watching
for the longest time,
replaying the moments most,
the highest clickthrough rate
of what looks most exciting.
So I am learning that you can work
with the new way that it's set up,
but it was definitely jarring
when it first happened
and no one knew or was
told what was happening.
- Just like flipped to
let's plays overnight.
- Yeah, yeah, 'cause
that was the fastest way
to make repeating long-form content
that people would feel the
need to watch entirely.
- Oh yeah, did you guys
start the gaming channel
around that time?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Is that why, 'cause of
the change, or was it just-
- We didn't know what the reason was
that these videos were
popping up, but we saw,
oh wait, gaming videos, that's
becoming really popular,
people wanna see this
and a lot of people are
asking us to play games.
- I get it, I'm a gamer.
- Yeah, I'm a gamer, I could do it.
- Did you have a hard time
when the algorithm did shift
and you were still on like,
scripted sketches and
everything like that?
- Yeah, yeah.
It was definitely a hard period.
I mean, it didn't really
affect us as much as
it probably could of.
- Yeah, you guys were
still going pretty strong.
- It was still fine and I looked recently,
we still have a lot of
videos from that time
that have like tens of millions of views,
so like, it was okay, it was okay,
but it definitely did impact the way
that the videos were pushed out initially.
So like after the first weekend,
I remember having a higher up
breathing down my neck saying,
"You guys usually get a million views
in the first three days, what's going on?"
And it was a lot of like
this stress of like,
what is going on, and
we're like, "I don't know,
we haven't been told!"
- You don't want the fucking
boss telling you that,
that's the last thing you want.
- And their entire company
and all the X amount of employees,
their livelihoods are built on
the performance of these videos.
- Yeah.
- Right, right.
- So at that time we were really pushed
to break off and create
other side channels
and experiment with longer-form content,
things that required less editing.
- I feel so lucky being just
like almost independent,
- Always been independent based.
- like a one, two-man team
with my own personal channel,
because that's just, the
pressure's just gone, you know?
- It's a lot less pressure.
- Yeah.
Okay, 'cause I gotta ask,
'cause I rarely meet someone
who's been on YouTube
for longer than me.
- For longer than most
of your viewers' lives.
(all laughing)
- Honestly!
- What a disturbing way of putting it.
- Honestly, yeah.
- I just interviewed Nihachu
who's this really popular
Twitch streamer and she's 19.
And I was like, "So I made my
YouTube when you were two,"
and it freaked me out.
- That's scary!
- It freaked me the fuck out.
- 'Cause I found out today actually,
that today out of complete coincidence
is my 15th-year anniversary on YouTube.
- Oh shit, I didn't realize
you were on that long too!
(Connor, Joey, and Anthony clapping)
Congratulations!
- You did it!
- So I rarely get to ask this,
so what is the secret to stay relevant
for a long period of time on YouTube?
- You're asking that?
- You've gone for 15 years!
- Because you've been
on for longer than me,
so you're the only one I can ask
for like a actual perspective, right?
- Okay, okay, well we could
share perspectives here,
because I think that you might have
something to contribute, Mr 15 years.
- I'll be Mr 17 years.
- 17 Years, talk to my
senior, my senior now.
- My YouTube career can
watch an R-rated movie,
but I can't quite vote or smoke.
(all laughing)
- Mine's in high school.
- Yeah, chilling.
- Yours is gonna be legal
next year, you know?
- You're getting your first zits
and being very uncomfortable about it.
- Your balls are dropping.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're very uncomfortable about puberty.
You're starting to get the
hang of it, no pun intended.
But let's see, so the secret,
the secret is to never feel
like you have it figured out.
- Right, yeah.
- The secret I think is to always feel
like there is something new to learn.
I am constantly looking at the people
that are growing audiences
and I'm kind of filtering out,
okay, this person,
they have a recipe and
it pleases the algorithm.
I think maybe that's why they have views.
Okay, what can I learn from that?
Okay, this person has a
really dedicated fan base.
They don't necessarily
appeal to the algorithm,
but they appeal to an audience,
and what can I learn from them?
So for me, it's really
about constantly learning.
And when I do interviews
with bigger names,
tomorrow I'm interviewing TommyInnit.
- Oh wow.
- Nice, nice.
- And he's like, is he 18?
- He just 17 I think.
- He's in his school, right?
- He's still in high school.
- He graduated?
- But like, I love picking his brain
and people that are new and
coming up on YouTube right now
and learning what they
see in the platform now,
because it's something
completely different.
And I feel like there is never a point
where you as a creator on the internet
where things are so rapidly changing,
there was never a point
where you will be like,
figured it out.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And I used to think
there would be a point
that I would be like,
I gotta grind and grind and grind
and eventually I'll have it figured out
and then I'll just be able to sit back
and let the thing just live on its own.
And I think that's kind
of what got me into
or convinced me that
selling to a company in 2011
was the right idea.
I had it in my head, the
goal is to figure this out,
it'll go on autopilot, I can relax
and maybe do other things in my life.
But what I quickly realized
is that I really love doing this
and this is part of my
life that I want to retain
and there will never be a point
where I feel satisfied just relaxing.
But also, if you sit back and relax, then-
- You get comfortable.
- Yeah, you get comfortable
and you lose track
of why things are moving in
the direction they're going
and what is relevant
to the platform today.
- Yeah, because that's
really interesting to hear,
because for your perspective,
you've really been one of the top creators
basically since the birth of YouTube,
whereas I've been on
YouTube for a long time,
but it's been like on a
very, very niche topic,
which is anime.
So I've always been able to learn
from what the bigger creators are doing
and try to apply what
everyone else is doing
and seeing if I can take that
into my own niche, my own channel,
and seeing if it can grow out of there.
- And how has that paid off?
Were you able to take those lessons
and things that you learned
from the bigger YouTubers
and apply it to yourself
and have it pay off?
- Yeah, I mean, it kind of
felt like a cheat sheet,
it kinda feel like cheating.
'Cause I'm just like, you know,
I'm in such a niche topic
that I could just take
what other people are doing
and just put it with my own content.
But with you, since you're one of
the people setting the standards,
one of the people that I
watched and I was like,
okay, let's see what Smosh is doing,
let's see what some of the other
bigger creatures are doing,
I'm like, okay, well, I see
what's successful to them.
But I feel like being at
the top of the pyramid
and trying to balance
yourself is a lot easier
than climbing up from
the bottom of the pyramid
and trying to like stay relevant.
- For sure, for sure.
- Yeah.
- I think that some people have a goal
of get to the top of this pyramid,
just stay afloat up here.
And of course, it is much more comfortable
because you have the freedom to kind of
apply more of these things that
you learn on a bigger scale.
But at the same time,
there's so much more pressure
and I think that that's
unforeseen to smaller creators.
I had my period, I left
Smosh when I think we had
22 or 23 million subscribers,
huge amount of subscribers,
huge amount of pressure.
I go off and do my own thing,
channel starts with a couple million
and they're people that don't
really know what to expect,
I don't know what to give them.
And there was still that
pressure there from me
of how am I going to
entertain these people
who expect me to be giving
the quality of content
of a 22-million subscriber
channel but now it's just me,
it's literally just me on my own.
- I'm really curious about,
obviously a lot of the viewers
when you said, "Ah, I'm leaving Smosh,"
I think a lot of people
would see that and think,
oh, he's just leaving a channel.
But I imagine there was a lot of
probably behind the scenes or friendships
that were strained by that.
Like outside of just the
business perspective,
did that put like a lot of
strain on your personal life,
like leaving that and
having to kind of be like,
all right, I'm leaving this big thing?
'Cause you know, obviously Ian is there
and a bunch of your friends worked there.
- Well surprisingly, me leaving
didn't put a strain in and of itself,
like the idea of me leaving
and then me leaving,
that didn't exactly put a strain.
I think maybe afterwards
it did a little bit,
really I think it was because audiences
or viewers and commenters
really were having all
these different things
that they were saying about like,
oh, this person's better
or this person's better,
or you were better when you were here
or they're better now that they're here,
and I think that that
added a little bit of,
it was unavoidable to see those.
- [Connor] Oh, yeah, yeah.
- I feel like you can't
turn off your brain
from wanting to keep up with the comments
even if you're not even
trying to look for them.
I'm trying to see what people are thinking
about this new thing that
I'm just trying to figure out
and then I'm getting inundated
with all these opinions from people.
And I think that that does seep in
when you're not ready for it.
I do wish that I was more ready
for the types of comments-
- How the fuck can you ready for that?
- The only way to be ready for
it I think is to live in it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
But I also realized that
there is a bit of freedom
in having a smaller audience.
So it was a huge struggle,
and my videos when I first left
I think got a million views
each for a couple months,
and I was like, "Oh, I
need to retain this."
And then very quickly, once
I think people realized
I didn't know what I was doing.
I had no goal for the channel.
I was like, "Each week we'll
figure out something new
and I hope you watch it."
And I quickly lost this
audience that I had
and realized that they
were not there just for me.
And it was a little bit
bit disappointing at first
'cause I thought, oh I guess I have
the freedom to do whatever,
and I thought that I had that with me.
And then it was a wake up call to realize,
oh, but you have to make good content,
you can't just expect them
to be there because it's you.
Egotistical maniac.
The views I think got to about
like 30,000 to 60,000 views a video.
- On the "Anthony Padilla" channel?
- On the "Anthony Padilla" channel
within the first year after.
- Really?
- And at that time, if
videos weren't getting
100,000 views or even more,
people in the comments are just like,
irrelevant, irrelevant, wow, fell off.
- L + ratio!
- L + ratio + you fell off!
(Garnt laughing)
- Yeah, yeah, a lot of that.
- You basically had abandoned an audience
for a different style,
so then obviously that's gonna happen.
But people don't see it like that.
They're like, oh, your
name's worth so much.
- They're like, what do you mean
you're not doing sketches anymore?
I thought you were gonna do
your own sketches now, right?
- And I thought that I had
to, I thought I was beholden.
And I think that the reason
that it got to that point
is I felt like I was
trapped in this idea of
I need to create sketches,
I need to be funny,
I need to deliver something
that appeases that audience
that I've learned how to appease.
And I think getting down to,
I call them lower numbers,
30 to 60k, I know a lot of
people are up and coming
and that is a great number,
I don't wanna discount that.
- I mean, perspective-wise, that's low.
- But at the same time,
I was kind of floundering
around at that number.
And first of all,
I had to get out of my head
from looking at the numbers.
It wasn't about that anymore.
I realized that I had an opportunity now
to experiment without the
pressure of an audience.
So that's when I started experimenting
with all these different types of videos
and all these different types of things
and that's when I fell into doing
"I Spent A Day With" videos,
and it was without that pressure.
And the first few did have that
pressure on me to be funny,
so I was kind of, you know,
"I spent a day with FLAT
EARTHERS" and it was kind like,
look how ridiculous these people are.
- Look how weird and wacky this is!
- These people are weird!
But slowly but surely over the next
couple months or half a year,
I started realizing that I
actually was really curious
about different types of people.
I did this video, "I
spent a day with FURRIES"
and I had a company help me
reach out to these people,
and I thought they were all local.
When they showed up,
I found out that one flew in
themselves on their own dime
and then this person like
drove three hours to be there.
And I was like, okay,
and I already wasn't planning
to say like, these people are weird,
but a part of me was like,
I don't understand this,
this is kind of a weird thing.
But they get there and they're saying,
"I used to watch Smosh all
the time, I love your stuff."
- You're fucking weird!
(all laughing)
- So anyway, why are you here?
- So I very quickly changed my perspective
with the way that I went
into that interview.
Like there was no way,
and it felt weird to me doing
the flat-Earther episode,
it felt weird to me,
like I was going outside of my element
to give the snarky commentary
channel perspective
that was really popular
on YouTube at the time.
I realized I was kind of falling into
those tropes that were so popular.
And I was like, I just feel
like I need to just be me
and have a conversation with someone,
be curious about them, try
to learn about their life.
And in doing so, afterward
I had them reach out to me,
they were really excited
about the way it turned out,
but also a lot of commenters were like,
"Whoa, this is the first
time I've ever seen
furries represented in a way
where they were treated with respect,
and that is so weird, I've
never seen that before.
I'm gonna send this to my
friends who don't understand me."
And it was really then
that I realized like,
oh, this is what actually feels right.
I'm not appeasing an audience
I think I should be appeasing
'cause it's the trendiness
of YouTube at the time
or like this sense of humor
that I felt like I needed to always be
this character that I was on Smosh.
I felt like I was able to
actually just be myself,
and my editor then
helped me throw in jokes,
but it wasn't up to me anymore,
I was just making a
connection with the person.
- Back to YouTube boomer talk.
- (laughs) Let's go, let's go!
- You talked about constantly learning,
constantly seeing what's out there.
There must have been a
point when you're just like,
I am so out of touch right now.
- Oh for sure!
- 'Cause I constantly feel that.
Sometimes I'm like, I get YouTube,
I get the algorithm,
I get all the content,
I get what people want to watch.
Sometimes you just see
something and you're like,
okay, I am a boomer.
You see that one popular
video, and you're like, why?
- Yeah.
- Why this?
- There is this one
channel called Weegeepie.
Have you heard of that?
- No.
- Okay.
So I don't know how they do it.
They have a 3D CG rig of Luigi
and they animate him and
his face to react to things,
or at least this is what the
channel was a few years ago,
I don't know what they're doing now.
So he was reacting to things
with Luigi sound effects,
so like, "Waa, whoa!"
And it was just like a
reaction channel by Luigi
and some of them had millions of views
and I was like, this is so bizarre.
- That sounds incredible!
- But I loved it.
- I reached out, I
followed him on Twitter.
I was like, "This shit, keep
it up, this shit's sick!"
But it was so weird,
and I was like, there is always
something to learn about YouTube.
There's always some weird corner.
- I mean, now you're exploring those.
- Yeah, now you're exploring, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, and those
are the types of people
that I really, really enjoy talking to
where it's this community
that's doing this thing
that many people would
just think is bizarre.
There's actually something to it
and why does it catch on,
and we could talk about
the emotional aspects
of like the connection that people make
and why do you think this is popular?
- I think it's just really refreshing.
I mean, obviously lately on the internet,
and even when you started
it, it was very combative
and everyone was always
at each other's throat,
and I think it just came out at the time
and kind of hit the
right note of just like,
let's just talk, let's just
learn about each other.
- Yeah.
- Just be open.
- And I think it's, yeah, the success,
it shows that the audiences
wanted that kind of content.
People are curious about all
the types of different things,
be it pony, pony?
- Pony players.
(Anthony laughing)
- I wanna know them, I wanna know why.
- In saying that though,
there have been a couple of
videos I've seen from yours
where you do kind of bring
back that old-school,
a little bit cynical type
of interviewer type thing.
The one about like you interviewing
time travelers for instance,
that one was like a little,
I saw the little bit of
the cynical side of you,
which was just as entertaining.
- You have to be though.
- You have to be.
- That was right after
the flat-Earthers episode,
so I didn't quite detach
from that side of it.
But I feel like now if I
were to approach that again,
the topic that I'm like
a little bit like, hm,
I think I would just outright say,
"This seems completely unbelievable.
Do you have people telling you that
and how do you feel about that?"
I feel like there's so many more
interesting conversations
to have about that,
and I think a lot of
people are either afraid
to tell someone that their shit's whack
or all they want to do is tell
them that their shit's whack
and they don't wanna hear
why they do what they do.
- Right.
- Right, right, right.
- I think that if you
could just be transparent
with anyone really,
like if you could just have
a conversation with anyone
about why they do what they do,
you can make some kind of a connection
regardless of who the person is,
except Hitler, not Hitler.
(Connor and Garnt laughing)
- Yeah, they grow up so fast.
He's maturing!
- How do you feel about TikTok?
'Cause if there's one thing
that does make me feel
like a boomer and out of touch,
it is just TikTok itself.
- Yeah, it's-
- Have you thought about
venturing into that?
- Oh, I have a TikTok channel.
- Yeah, I showed a clip
from TikTok, right?
- It does really well with just clips
from my interview series cut down.
- Yeah, we did that as
well for Trash Taste.
- Yeah, yeah, does it
work for you guys too?
- Yeah.
- It works pretty well.
- I think that the thing about TikTok
is that there is an
audience for everything.
So you might log on and think
this is fucking weird shit,
but then there is a corner of the internet
that is for you on TikTok,
and their algorithm is really good
at feeding you content eventually.
If you sift through enough
garbage for enough time
it eventually will find
the thing that sits.
- My favorite category of TikTok videos
is somebody complaining about
something really specific,
and then someone's like,
"Hi, I'm the expert on that actually.
This is actually why it works."
And then it's like, who
is the toenail expert?
Where did you come from?
- It's literally IRL Reddit, right?
- Yeah.
- Yeah!
- Toenail expert here,
let me explain to you.
- It's just like the
strangest experts all come out
and they're all good looking.
That's the other thing,
everyone who is an expert on something
is just amazing looking.
- There is always an
expert about everything.
- And they look amazing.
- And they always look amazing.
- It's like, why did you have
to be so good and charming?
- Did they become good looking
because they're an expert,
which one came first?
- They became an expert
then they have the time
to go and work out and
take care of themselves.
- Or is it that most people that look good
or bound to be experts.
- I used to be a model,
now I'm a toenail expert.
(Anthony and Garnt laughing)
- It is really crazy.
Yeah, it's such a cool platform,
but it makes me feel really old.
- And it's weird because I
thought it was gonna die.
- I think everyone when it was bought,
when it was Musical.ly-
- Yeah, yeah.
- Oh yeah.
- I thought it was gonna go
down the Vine route back then.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Musical.ly was the thing
and everyone was doing the
Musical.ly cringe compilations.
I think everyone just thought,
oh, that's just for kids,
and then TikTok blew up and then,
wow, everyone was wrong.
I think everyone thought it was gonna die.
- Yeah, yeah.
When everyone just was just like
that lip syncing or doing dances,
and it was just like,
look at this funny thing
the kids are doing.
- The replies, man.
- Anthony was like, I did
that so many years ago!
- I built my career that way!
- They took my shit!
- I think it's the replies,
the replies and the ability
to share the music so easily
just was this game-changer, I think.
And it made editing kind
of accessible to the,
I mean, editing, very
accessible to beginners
and people who don't know it.
It's like, just slide this thing across,
chop the video, chuck it
in, put this music over it.
And oh, you want a funny filter?
We've got that too.
- True, true.
- So it kind of made it less scary.
I mean, you open up DaVinci Resolve
and you just have a panic attack.
You're like, what the fuck is this?
This makes no sense.
Adobe Premiere, it makes zero sense
if you don't watch five
hours of YouTube tutorials.
So I feel like it kind of
made it very accessible
in a way that kind of just worked.
- And TikTok is always
changing their shit.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, it is.
- If you look at TikTok
now versus a year ago,
it looks very different,
and for that and the
features that they add,
they are doing the upkeep.
Vine, I mean, I think it
was clear why Vine died,
for many reasons,
one being that you
couldn't make money on it,
but also they were not keeping it up,
they were not updating it.
And fortunately or not, things
on the internet platforms
need to constantly be updated
to go where people are wanting it to go.
'Cause it is ultimately for people, right?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Instead Vine opted to be like,
what if we made a sequel to Vine?
Let's make a Vine 2.
- Did they ever do that?
- I don't think they did, no.
- No, no, no.
- Were those rumors or were those legit?
- They were legit, yeah.
Vine was like, we're
coming back with Vine 2.
- And then TikTok was like, nah.
- Yeah, TikTok was like, no, we got this,
we got this, don't worry.
- We're way ahead of you!
- Well, I find it really weird,
'cause I feel like now
TikTok is what YouTube was
10, 15 years ago.
- True, true.
- Remember when in back
in the day where YouTubers
would try to get on TV,
which was like the old media,
in order to legitimize themselves.
And now it's TikTokers
trying to become YouTubers
in order to-
- Oh, for sure.
- To legitimize themselves.
And it's been so weird just
seeing that transition.
- That's so true.
I guess it's because the
platform is so easily accessible.
Like you were saying that
anyone could jump on there
and you can build an audience on there,
people can find you, the
algorithm is very good.
So it's basically like if early YouTube
had an algorithm that fed people content
that was directly relevant to them.
- Yeah, and I think it's also
the barrier for entry for YouTube now,
I feel like even though YouTube is like,
you can make anything on
YouTube and it'll be successful,
still the quality of
content on YouTube now
is so much higher than
it was 10, 15 years ago.
- We're in like the Mr. Beast era
where everything has to
be $100,000, I did this!
I fucking stayed up for one week straight!
It's like, all right, okay,
I can't compete with that
'cause I just don't wanna do that!
- Have you seen any of
Ryan Trahan's stuff?
- I have, I have.
- I have, of course.
- So I feel like he's been reinventing
what YouTubers can now expect
to do with the platform,
because he's taking some
elements of the Mr. Beast style
with thumbnails that
look very nice and clean
and he has an elevated
concept for this whole thing
and it feels like a video game,
it feels like you're watching
this person's journey
unfold in front of you
and you feel like you can't click away
'cause you never know what's
gonna happen in any turn,
but yet it is still a vlog.
And he can still, because it is a vlog
where the whole idea is
that it's low produced,
he's able to make one a day.
- It's quite nice just watching it,
and you're like, this is nice.
I just feel like it's not too crazy.
- It's nostalgic.
- I love watching a Mr. Beast video,
but my God, I feel like
I'm a cog in a machine.
- [Anthony] Yes, yes, yes, absolutely!
- It's so much.
- And there's so much streaming and text.
It feels like a refined, modernized vlog
that has yeah kind of
like an elevated gameplan.
- The thumbnails are just the next level.
- The thumbnails kill it.
And I never would've thought
that a vlog thumbnail
which is not clickbait,
'cause it's not clickbait,
can look so good, right?
- Yeah.
- I don't know who does it.
- I remember when back when YouTuber vlogs
were just you put on any
digital camera, handheld camera,
and then Casey Neistat came
along and just used a DSLR
and made basically like
mini short films every day.
And people were like, what?
You can do that, that's possible?
And then everyone tried to
be Casey Neistat for a while.
- And then he burnt out.
- I mean he was, every day.
I mean, when he used to
talk about his schedule,
he was like, "Yeah, I'd wake up at 4:00 AM
and I'm editing it on the plane."
I'm like, what the fuck!
- But I think what we can
learn from that experience
is that if you have something good,
you don't need to overdo it.
If you want it to have any longevity,
part of the game plan
is to figure out a way
for it not to take up your entire life.
I interviewed Markiplier and he was like,
"Burnout is when people
aren't refilling their bucket,
they're constantly scooping
out of their bucket for their content
and they're not refilling it
because they're not living
a life outside of that."
You need to have that balance.
- Have you ever been burnt out?
- Yes, absolutely.
(all laughing)
- I would've been shocked if you said no.
- I should've been like, never, never.
Always a creative high.
- 17 years strong baby!
- I was trying to be polite.
The question should be,
so when did you burn out?
(all laughing)
- Honestly, you should have
just said it like that!
Many different times,
and every single time is
when I felt overworked.
And then once it became
like part of a company,
overworked, underappreciated.
Felt like I wasn't being,
like my opinions didn't quite
contribute to the creative.
But then also outside of that,
I was burnt out on my own outside of Smosh
after I left and decided
to do my own thing.
For a lot of that time, when
the views were dropping,
I was also burnt out
so it makes sense that people
were not wanting to watch the content
of someone who was burnt the
fuck out by their own content.
That's like, that's not fun to watch.
There's a feeling you can feel
when someone is burnt
out by their content.
- Yeah, and then when you
go to the the actual video
and the top comment is like,
"He's run out of ideas."
- Yeah, yeah, I'm like, "Fuck you dude!
I got so many ideas."
And I just sit there and
I'm like, "I have no ideas!
They were right."
- Call me out.
- But you know, I think I
really started to reframe
what was important to me
and then I started not
taking it as seriously,
not putting as much of my time into it,
and I was able to live
a life outside of it
and have thoughts that
were separate from my work,
and I think it kind of helped
reinvigorate to a certain degree.
- Yeah, one thing I was gonna ask is like,
because, compared to you
YouTube boomers right here,
we are very much children.
- Oh yeah, nine years,
seven years right there.
- It's nine years, seven years.
I just discovered what boogers taste like.
So it's like, what I wanted
to ask you specifically
is how much of longevity do you see
as a YouTuber being a career?
Because it's like, we
don't really have any,
'cause like say with Hollywood
or the acting industry or music industry,
we already have examples of people
who have had careers for like
30, 40, 50 years plus, right?
But because YouTube is such a new thing,
whereas I think the longest
is probably someone like you.
It's like, do you see yourself doing this
for the next 10, 15 years again?
- I mean, it's already been half my life.
So it feels like I can give my confidence
to the idea that YouTube will
be around for a long time.
They haven't made any glaring mistakes
that are still glaring mistakes.
It feels like they they've
made a ton of mistakes,
absolutely, I'm not gonna
write them off completely.
- Right, right, right.
- Yeah.
- But it seems like over time
they are remedying a lot of those,
it feels like they actually
are caring about the community.
There's plenty of issues,
but it seems like enough people care
to make changes to keep
the platform relevant.
- 'Cause like, oh, go on, go on.
- Oh, I completely lost my, say what.
- I was gonna say,
'cause obviously people are gonna be like,
"What do you mean, they
did this fucking thing!"
And it's like, I think,
as you were saying,
as a whole platform, I think they meant,
considering the amount of shit
that goes on the platform,
they do a pretty good job
at keeping it relevant,
pushing it forward, and
making it the place.
Yeah, obviously there's places
where they fuck up massively.
- Yeah, because I think definitely
the one moment that YouTube
like did a fuckie-wuckie
and everyone was like,
this is the end of YouTube
was when demonetization
became a thing, right?
And the adpocalypse came up.
Everyone unanimously was like, this is it.
This is where it dies.
But it somehow managed
to stick around for what,
five extra years?
- That needed to happen though.
Looking back at it, it
was an inevitability
that it was gonna come to something like,
a system like that was gonna
have to be put in place.
- They implemented a lot of things
that help with that though.
Like on the backend, you
can upload a video now
and it'll say, I'm not
sure if it's for everyone,
I think it's for everyone,
please correct me if I'm wrong.
I don't wanna be like-
- You get YouTube privileges?
- YouTube privilege right here!
- I'm like, YouTube's great!
And you're like, bro, we do
not have any of those features.
- Well, let's find out.
- The 1%.
- Okay, so what I will say
is when I upload a video,
it says checking on the monetization,
and then after a half hour,
45 minutes, an hour, whatever,
it eventually does like the initial check
and then you can have some confidence
that it probably caught it
if it's gonna catch something
that you shouldn't have in the video.
So that has given me a lot of confidence
in the direction of that,
because monetization was a huge issue.
Every time I'd upload for a while,
I was like, mm, I don't know, let's see,
this thing I put tens of
thousands of dollars into,
it might be worth nothing.
I might just could be in the red for this.
They did fix some things I feel,
and they're slowly but surely I think
fixing a lot of the glaring issues.
- Was there like a point
where this changed from,
because as with the way
being a content creator is,
this changed from being a job to a career?
Because for the longest time,
I treated YouTube as a job
because you wake up and you're like,
maybe I'll be irrelevant
tomorrow, a week from now, a year.
And I didn't really feel
like this was a career
literally until this
podcast when I'm just like,
oh, okay, this is like
a sustainable business
that I can see myself 5,
10 years in the future.
Was there a point for that for you?
- I think the moment that that changes
with somebody in general
is probably when you have a format
that you can come back
to and feel confident in,
and that's probably why
this podcast was like,
we know the format, it's
kind of all figured out
so that it feels like
this is a repeating thing.
For me it was, I think it
probably felt like career
when we were purchased by Defy,
because it was like-
- Salary.
I mean, that kind of I feel
like it was unique to me though.
But then after that,
going off independently,
the moment that it felt
like a career for me now
was when I had a series,
"I Spent A Day With,"
to go back to.
I knew that it was a repeating thing.
- Like a safety net, like
something comfort, you know?
- I think that's the difference,
when you know that you have something,
you're not starting from
square one every single video.
A lot of people are still
trying to figure out
what they're doing,
so every single video is
back to the drawing board
and then that just feels like a job,
and trust me, it's tough.
- Yeah, because I feel like
when you're starting off a YouTube,
you want to make every
video a 10 out 10 banger.
You wanna be motivated,
you wanna do something new every time,
then you realize that after
a year or two of doing it,
you're like, this is
not sustainable at all.
I need some kind of formula
that I can fall back on
because I can't always be
at my peak of creativity every time.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- So you guys are like 90%,
probably going into each episode,
90% sure where things
are gonna go, you know?
- Yeah.
- Hmm.
- Well, going back to the
beginning of this episode, right?
- We know roughly, we know roughly.
- We know roughly, yeah.
- You know a little bit
about what the dynamic is
gonna be like at least.
- I know if I say this
thing, how maybe he'll react.
- Your face is not so sure.
(Garnt laughing)
- I'm like, all I know
is that we're gonna have
someone on the show
and we're gonna be
talking about their stuff.
- Well you have a name
and you have sponsors.
- So yeah, exactly, exactly.
- Yeah, I guess like, sorry.
- No, I was just saying,
I feel like in a weird way,
we are still trying to figure out
that formula for Trash Taste in a sense.
It's like, we've kind of figured it out.
It's obviously a lot-
- 100 episodes deep, don't
know what the fuck's going on.
(Anthony and Garnt laughing)
- 100 episodes deep right,
but it's like, I am personally always
scared of that moment where
it starts to get repetitive
or starts to really feel like a job.
And luckily I don't feel
that way right now about it.
But it's like, I am
scared to fall into that.
- So what are you doing to prevent it
from feeling like it's a repetitive job?
- I mean, we're bringing it on tour now.
- That's the one.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, we're filming overseas,
we're getting all sorts
of interesting guests
and stuff like that
and I think the specials definitely help.
Where that's the moment where we can just
kind of really explode without creativity.
- But also like those specials
probably are what excite
the audience as well, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I hope so.
- Hope so, right guys, right?
- Every now and then someone will be like,
"Where's our four hour conversation?
I wanted to go to work
and listen to four hours
and not watch one hour of content!"
- Yeah, yeah.
I guess my final question is
what do you want to do in the future?
I mean, you've been on
the platform 17 years.
- Are you gonna do something
for your 20th anniversary?
- Got nothing planned, man,
but 21st, you don't know.
(Connor, Joey, and Garnt laughing)
I mean, I just wanna
continue refining what I do.
That's what I've been enjoying doing most.
This "I Spent a Day With"
series has been so fun for me
'cause every single episode,
I see at least one element
that I wanna refine,
whether it's the lighting on the set
or something that's really
technical like that.
Or it's like my performance on the intros
feels like I'm just reading words,
I'm gonna revamp that and try to learn it.
Or like, I just went all
out and I did these tests
where I reshot some of my
intros where I have a jib,
which is like a fucking
little crane on to a camera.
And I was like, 'cause
I was watching a bunch
of really big YouTubers,
like Airrack for example.
And I was like, he has these intros
where he's choreographed this scene.
There's one that he did about like,
what would you do if you
had one day left to live?
So he starts off and it's
like the doctor saying,
"You have one day left to live,"
and he's like in these
bandages and then he's like,
he just gets up and he gets
out and the doctor's like,
"Where are you going?"
And he's like ripping off
his bandages and stuff,
he's talking the camera and he's like,
"What would you do if you
had one day left to live?"
And he's saying this to the audience
and he's bringing us through
the camera, it's following him,
and it's this choreograph scene
that just immediately right
off the the bat you know,
there was this effort that went into this,
this is a good setup for this video.
'Cause I know that if
the rest of this video
is anything like these first 30 seconds,
it's gonna be so much fun.
So I was like, how could I
apply some of these things
that I'm seeing modern YouTubers do
and apply it to an interview format?
And I was like, well, I
can kind of choreograph
the way that I say these things.
So I'm still learning with that.
And so it's hard to say
where I want to go next,
but I think more importantly,
I know where I want to go now
and that's to constantly refine
and not allow myself to get bored
because I wanna always creatively
see what is right out of my comfort zone.
- That's pretty cool
that you've been on YouTube for that long
and you're like, I still
want to get inspiration.
- I was about to say,
that's very humbling.
- Yeah, it's inspiring to hear that
you are still on your journey, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- After 17 years, you're
still on your journey
and you're still figuring stuff out.
- Yeah, because in my head I was like,
Damn, I've been doing
this shit for nine years.
I don't know what fuck the I'm doing.
I'm glad to know someone
who's been doing it
for almost double that also doesn't know.
- No, I'm just having fun, man.
If I enjoy what I'm doing,
I feel like that is the best
career that you could have,
is where you enjoy it.
- Yeah, definitely.
- Not the career that
unfolds in this timeline
that I prebuilt in my
head for where it goes.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Right.
- You hear that, guys?
It's not about the money.
(all laughing)
It's about the love for it.
- Well, yeah, thank you
so much for coming on.
- Oh my God, thank you guys.
- Thank you, this was awesome,
this was so cool.
- Hey, but look at all
these patrons though.
- Do you see all of them?
- Oh shit!
- Oh my God, look at them!
- Look at all these
patrons just coming down.
- Become a patron immediately,
this show is dope.
Don't forget it!
- Who's your favorite patron?
I like that one.
- That one right there in the middle.
It's already gone, but I did enjoy it.
- Hey, if you'd like to support the show,
go to our Patreon, patreon.com/trashtaste.
Also follow us on Twitter,
send us some memes on the subreddit,
and if you hate our face,
listen to us on Spotify.
And yeah, go check out Anthony's stuff.
I don't need to tell you that.
Everyone should know.
- Well I hope we did an okay
job interviewing you for once.
- Oh my God, absolutely, absolutely.
I've never done a three on one before,
it's always been a one on three.
Thank you for putting me in
the reverse position, guys.
- Hopefully we're gonna hear
about our skills later on,
you'll write it all down as a score.
- I'll talk about this experience
on another episode of my show.
- Ah, hell yeah.
- You won't know when it's coming.
- You're just gonna
throw it in and be like,
"Oh yeah, so about the pony thing,
by the way, Trash Taste is shit."
- "So I came in there and
they didn't know anything,
they didn't know anything!
They weren't even prepared!"
- Your such a better guest
than Trash Taste was,
and they weren't even
guests, they were hosts!
(all laughing)
No, you guys are great.
- Hell yeah, dude.
- I appreciate it.
- Thank you so much, man.
- Thank you, guys.
- Oh, thank you.
- And thanks for watching, guys.
See you on the next one.
- [Joey And Garnt] Bye!
- [Anthony] Bye-bye.
(mellow music)